[Musique]
Jean-Marc Jancovici bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement Jean-Marc
Jancovici aux dernières nouvelles de
sexe masculin je pars trader dans ce
studio
je travaille dans une société qui
s'appelle carbone 4 qui essaye de
confronter les activités économiques à
la contrainte énergie et climat je suis
président d'une association qui
s'appelle Dechy projett qui est le
pendant militant on va dire de la même
chose je suis à mes heures perdues
et à mes heures encore plus perdu
j'écris de temps en temps quelque chose
qui essaye de compenser le 4 sur 20 que
j'ai magistralement reçu à l'écrit du
bac de français il y a très longtemps
félicitations
donc monsieur Jancovici Jean-Marc on a
décidé de vous faire venir aujourd'hui
pour parler sobriété des carbonations
peut-être un peu mais surtout la
différence entre une sobriété voulue et
une sobriété subie c'est quoi c'est
c'est Bruno Le Maire qui nous fait des
discours économiques que tout va bien et
que l'inflation va partir comme elle est
venue c'est est-ce que nos politiques
sont pas trop déconnectés des réalités
physiques que ça implique d'avoir une
décroissance ou une déconsommation
pour commencer par le début de la
question en fait depuis que je
m'intéresse à la question des économies
d'énergie puisque la sobriété c'est une
branche ou un embranchement on va dire
de ces économies j'ai fini par arriver à
une nomenclature qui est la suivante
quand on cherche à économiser de
l'énergie ou économiser n'importe quoi
en fait il y a trois manières de
s'attaquer aux problèmes il y en a une
première que on adore qui s'appelle
l'efficacité or l'efficacité en gros
c'est je fais toujours la même chose
j'ai toujours une voiture qui va à la
même vitesse qui contient le même nombre
de personnes plus le canari et le chat
qui a la même autonomie mais l'affaire
fonctionner consomme moins d'énergie ça
c'est dans l'efficacité et en fait on a
tous en tête l'idée que bah oui s'il y a
parc constant et à usage constant on met
de l'efficacité partout globalement on
arrivera à baisser la consommation
globale
il y a une deuxième branche qui
s'appelle la sobriété alors la sobriété
c'est je fais plus la même chose donc je
vais plus en voiture je vais en train
donc je change mon usage mais au passage
je récupère une économie une
déconsommation pour dire de quelque
chose et là en l'occurrence si je prends
l'exemple de la voiture et du train
c'est de l'énergie et puis il y a une
troisième branche des économies
d'énergie qui s'appelle la pauvreté qui
est très exactement la même chose que la
sobriété en termes physiques sauf que la
sobriété j'ai été acteur de mon
changement alors que la pauvreté je suis
je subis dit autrement je suis sobre si
délibérément je me dis quand même c'est
vachement sympa de prendre le train je
vais avoir le temps de lire etc et puis
à l'arrivée je dois aller un vélo et ça
sera très bon pour mon cardio et c'est
très différent de dire j'ai plus de quoi
payer le plein dans ma voiture et alors
que j'avais strictement pas l'intention
du tout de prendre le train ou de
prendre un vélo ou de marcher à pied ou
de renoncer à mon déplacement je vais le
faire quand même mais de façon subie
donc en fait en fait la différence entre
la sobriété et la pauvreté c'est juste
une affaire j'ai envie de dire sociale
ou comportemental ou mental c'est pas
une affaire physique c'est exactement
les mêmes traductions physiques sauf que
dans un cas de figure j'agis dans
l'autre cas de figure je subis et
effectivement quand on est dans un
contexte dans lequel il y a une
contrainte globale qui va s'appliquer
alors prenons l'exemple de l'énergie
puisque c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
Europe il y a une contrainte globale qui
s'applique qui s'appliquait une
contrainte qui s'appliquait déjà avant
la guerre en Ukraine et qui s'applique
encore plus depuis la guerre en Ukraine
qui est que il y a plus assez dans le
monde de production de pétrole pour tous
les gens qui en voudraient il y a plus
assez de production de gaz pour tous les
gens qui en voudraient le gars c'est
plutôt régional donc ça peut assez
production de gaz en Europe on va dire
pour que quand on regarde la
consommation énergétique de l'Europe en
fait elle a subi une inflexion très
brusque en 2006
qui est juste avant le pic de production
du pétrole conventionnel dans le monde
pétrole conventionnel c'est tout ce qui
est pas les sables bitumineux et le
pétrole de schiste
de 2008 et juste avant la crise de 2008
et juste après le pic de production de
gaz dans la mer du Nord qui à l'époque
faisait plus de la moitié de
l'approvisionnement gazier de l'Europe
donc l'Europe elle est en décrue
énergétique subie depuis le milieu des
années 2000
on va dire donc ça se traduit par des
flux physiques qui baissent et après
selon la manière dont l'Insee va
comptabiliser les services ça va se
traduire par une récession ou pas et
pour le moment on a trouvé tous les
artefacts qui allaient bien pour que ça
se traduise pas par une récession mais
si on regarde les flux physique par
exemple le nombre de mètres carrés qu'on
construit par an le nombre de tonnes
qu'on charge dans les camions etc
l'Europe est en décrue physique la
production industrielle enfin tous ces
trucs là en fait on est en décrue suit
depuis
on va dire de quelques pourcents c'est
pas quelque chose de massif à ce stade
et ça c'est également traduit d'une
certaine manière par l'érosion du
pouvoir d'achat des Français dont le
revenu disponible diminue depuis 2010
donc ça fait plus de 10 ans que en
moyenne donc sauf à part
les gens qui sont très à l'aise dont je
fais partie la quasi-totalité des
Français ils voient plutôt leurs revenus
mensuel c'est rodé depuis cette période
là donc en fait quand on est dans une et
la raison à la base elle est physique
d'accord donc quand on a une contrainte
physique globale qui s'applique
malheureusement si on n'a pas la
sobriété on aura la pauvreté alors la
sobriété elle demande une préparation
des esprits quand on a toujours eu
l'habitude de prendre sa voiture parce
qu'on trouvait sa commode parce qu'on
trouvait que c'était statutairement bien
ça montrait aux autres qu'on avait les
moyens etc se mettre dans l'état
d'esprit que tout d'un coup ce qui est
très bien c'est de faire l'exact inverse
c'est long en fait ça prend souvent une
génération ce changement de truc on le
voit par exemple chez les agriculteurs
passer du conventionnel au bio c'est
l'affaire d'une génération c'est les
enfants qui font différemment des
parents et donc changer les mentalités
c'est long et donc si on veut tabler sur
la sobriété en fait c'est essentiel
d'anticiper on sait pas bien faire de la
sobriété sans anticiper et sans
planifier quand on est pris de court en
pratique on peut appeler ça de la
sobriété ce que c'est réellement c'est
plutôt de la pauvreté avec la
nomenclature que je viens d'évoquer
alors
j'entends comme vous avez pu le voir qui
a fait briller mes yeux le mot anticiper
c'était peut-être un peu écrit et cousu
de fil blanc ce qui est en train de nous
arriver en termes de consommation
énergétique avec les dépressions qu'on
peut avoir sur certains champs gaziers
pétroliers air certains pays qui parlent
beaucoup de pétrole et des choses comme
ça c'était cousu de fibres pourquoi on
en est arrivé pourquoi on en arrive à
voir nos politiques courir comme des
canards sans tête ou des poulets sans
tête parce que c'était pas planifié
parce que Jean-Marc Jancovici n'a pas
essayé de leur tirer la sonnette
d'alarme depuis pratiquement plus d'une
décennie est-ce que c'est parce que ça
les ennuie parce que dire que on rentre
dans une des crues énergétique de
consommation bah ça induit des
répercussions sur notre organisme
productif notre organisme de service
public et ainsi de suite pourquoi c'est
pas anticipé alors il y a un peu de tout
ça
là il y a une partie de la réponse qui
est en fait on sait pas bien quoi faire
si on accepte ces prémices c'est à dire
si on accepte l'hypothèse de départ on
sait à chaud là on a pas la boîte à
outils pour savoir comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise au mieux et on n'a pas non
plus la boîte à outils pour faire le
lien entre les flux physiques et
l'économie en fait quand on regarde la
façon dont est théorisé l'économie
aujourd'hui les fonctions de production
par exemple n'inclut pas l'énergie elle
n'inclut pas les flux physiques les
fonctions de production suppose souvent
que toutes les ressources sont
substituables entre elles en fait la le
capital est indifférencier dans la
fonction de production donc la
compétence de la personne qui est en
train de m'interviewer qui est un
élément de capital ou les mètres carrés
sur lesquels je suis assis en ce moment
qui est un élément de capital une forme
de substituabilité entre les deux et
voilà si on a moins de là on peut faire
un peu plus de l'autre et on s'en sort
toujours
donc en fait la façon dont on a théorisé
l'économie
demande un gros effort de réflexion moi
ça m'a demandé des années enfin je veux
dire alors que j'étais dedans au
quotidien
c'est très prétentieux d'arriver à se
faire à l'idée que l'économie avec
laquelle tout le monde fonctionne
possède un énorme angle mort qui permet
pas de voir arriver un certain
prétentieux de penser ça est-ce que ça
vient qui je suis pour qui je suis pour
me dire ce qu'on m'a enseigné à l'école
l'économie qu'on m'a appris de la
formation le fait qu'on n'arrive pas à
en penser en dehors de la boîte et qu'on
n'arrive pas à modéliser bien sûr que
oui puisque la formation c'est la
reproduction des schémas d'organisation
qui ont permis aux précédents de de s'en
sortir donc en fait c'est à ça que ça
sert la formation c'est je vais
t'apprendre le monde et ainsi tu auras
des repères et tu pourras mieux t'en
sortir bon donc c'est vraiment à ça que
ça sert donc si les repères qu'on
fournis sont des repères qui sont
imparfaits ça demande un gros effort sur
soi-même de l'accepter déjà ça parce
qu'on se dit c'est pas possible qu'on
les raconter des garabistouilles c'est
que l'ensemble du système soit basé sur
des carabist je le redis c'est
monstrueusement prétentieux de penser ça
donc ça demande à sa demande à y compris
enfin moi ça m'a demandé un gros effort
sur moi-même de figure par accepter
cette conclusion alors aujourd'hui je
suis très à l'aise avec mais c'est pas
rapide donc quand on regarde la façon
encore une fois dans l'économie est
théorisée on se rend compte que dans la
théorie économique on a pas besoin de
l'énergie on en a pas besoin on a du
capital on a du travail et on a de la
production c'est comme ça que ça marche
l'énergie est un facteur de production
parmi d'autres si on en a moins on aura
plus d'autres choses c'est pas très
grave on est même pas capable de
comprendre que la diffusion du progrès
technique c'est de l'énergie pour être
capable de fabriquer en grande quantité
des objets qui comportent une nouveauté
faut de l'énergie des fois pour être
capable de les faire fonctionner il faut
de l'énergie aussi donc en fait on a on
arrive pas aujourd'hui et une fois qu'on
a bâti pardon un capital intellectuel
accumulé de deux siècles
même basé sur des actions de départ qui
sont pas les bons c'est inenvisageable
de tout jeter à la poubelle en disant
qu'on repart de zéro on est quasiment à
poil donc on est prisonnier de nos
schémas mentaux de nos façons de
fonctionner etc alors le monde politique
du système et de l'inertie du système
donc le monde politique est dans mais il
est pas seul
il y a encore pas plus tard qu'elle a
qu'à l'université d'été du Medef il y a
une semaine le nouveau président du
Medef a dit ce qu'on vit c'est la
croissance donc Patrick Martin donc
alors je le blâme pas en tant que tel il
faut bien voir que patron du Medef c'est
déjà un poste politique on est déjà au
service de ces adhérents donc on leur
dit un peu ce qu'ils ont envie
d'entendre quand même mais il n'empêche
que on est aujourd'hui dans un dans un
dans un système dans lequel c'est très
très difficile on a un gros paquebot
avec un tout petit gouvernail quoi c'est
c'est vraiment ça le c'est vraiment ça
le sujet donc les politiques ils sont là
dedans comme les autres après il faut
voir que le métier de politique une fois
qu'on est en fonction enfin quand le
politique je parle de ministre je parle
de députés je parle de président etc je
parle pas du maire de ma commune
et bien quand on est politique en
fonction en fait on est dans une
lessiveuse il faut bien comprendre que
une fois regarde disait très justement
le job de Premier ministre consiste à
prendre toutes les deux minutes une
décision sur un dossier qu'on a pas eu
le temps de regarder
paix à son âme parce que je pense que
c'était un type que on a un peu raté
mais et donc juste avant de je vais me
permettre une expression juste avant de
caler il a quand même tiré la sonnette
d'alarme une dernière fois il est je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui avait
un vrai goût pour le service de la
collectivité
voilà encore une fois bon il a
probablement eu quelques travers qu'il a
développé dans l'exercice de son métier
mais je pense qu'à la base il y avait
quelque chose de sincère
mais peu importe donc pour en revenir à
ce que je disais une fois qu'on est dans
le bon lui il y a très justement dit une
fois qu'on est dans la dans la au
pouvoir on est dans une lessiveuse et
donc on a très peu de temps pour prendre
du recul et changer sa manière de voir
le monde on a très très peu de temps
pour ça or moi l'essentiel de ce qui m'a
permis de faire le chemin que j'ai fait
en comprenant que c'était les flux
physiques qui structuraient l'économie
je les fais en baladant sur des sentiers
de montagne je l'ai fait en ayant des
périodes de 15 jours pendant lesquelles
j'étais pas dans un dans le quotidien en
ayant etc c'est pas pour rien que dans
l'ancien temps il y avait que les nobles
et les rentiers qui avaient du temps
pour penser parce que quand on est dans
quand on a besoin d'assurer au quotidien
des tâches opérationnelles qui vous
bouffent complètement l'énergie et
l'esprit on n'a pas le temps pour
prendre du recul donc le politique
moderne ou la politique moderne n'a pas
ce temps là pour prendre du recul et
donc c'est très très difficile pour eux
alors ils ont pas ce temps-là et par
ailleurs derrière ils ont pas la boîte à
outils admettons que demain matin on
postule que l'économie française pour
les 50 prochaines années ça tendance
naturelle va être de décroître on fait
quoi d'accord qui a réfléchi à comment
est-ce qu'on gère les hôpitaux les
retraites le salaire minimum l'école et
cetera personne donc on n'a pas la bonne
boîte à outils pour comprendre le lien
entre les ressources naturelles et le
fonctionnement économique et du coup on
n'a pas la bonne boîte à outils pour
gérer un système dans lequel il y a l'un
des pieds du tabouret la convive de
faire passer là ou pas alors oui parce
que je pense que une alors la la manière
de corriger ça elle est très lente elle
s'appelle multiplier les thèses c'est à
dire faut prendre le problème à la
racine l'innovation dans la recherche et
dans la et dans la représentation et
dans les modèles dans les schémas
mentaux qu'on a ça se passe chez les
jeunes en début de carrière c'est à ce
moment là que on peut faire des choses
que les autres n'ont pas faites donc en
fait si on veut révolutionner l'économie
ça doit passer par des thèses c'est à
dire un nombre croissant de gens qui
travaillent sur des problèmes nouveaux
et ils le font au moment où ils sont pas
encore prisonniers de leur rendre
intellectuelle donc c'est au moment de
la thèse que ça soit non mais moi je
suis déjà prisonnier de marante
intellectuelle c'est absolument évident
donc il faut le faire au moment où les
gens sont encore ou encore pas d'attache
de ce point de vue et c'est à ce
moment-là que donc oui effectivement il
faut que dans les labos qui acceptent
d'être un peu à la marge ou de etc il
faut consacrer des thèses à comment
est-ce que on fait la boîte à outils qui
va nous permettre de gérer avec un monde
macroscopiquement parce que micro
microscopiquement on sait faire je
fabrique des câbles en cuivre j'ai moins
de cuivre bah je regarde comment je
m'organise au besoin je fais des trucs
douloureux je me sépare d'une partie des
gens qui bossent je vends en moins de
monde mais mais j'ai une boîte à outils
je suis pas complètement à poil en terme
de méthode au niveau de la de la
collectivité dans son ensemble et
notamment au niveau de l'État on sait
pas faire la politique
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui ils ont pas
la boîte à outils pour ça donc quand ils
sont confrontés à ce genre de situation
ils naviguent un peu à vue on le voit
bien on voit bien
c'est la manière un peu provocante de
dire la même chose
va vous poser une question un peu plus
personnelle
cette prise de conscience
ce myosis de la perception de de
ce grand brouhaha qui qui était venu à
l'esprit quand tu as pris conscience de
notre
dépendance à l'énergie et des
répercussions que ça pouvait avoir
qu'est-ce qu'il a créé c'est la marche
en montagne c'est un c'est quoi c'est
venu du bilan carbone en fait c'est à
dire que au début quand j'ai commencé à
travailler sur quelqu'un à quoi pouvait
servir un bilan carbone j'avais en tête
purement le problème climatique la seule
chose que qui m'intéressait c'était de
me dire on va réaliser pour des
activités économiques un inventaire de
toutes les émissions dont dépend cette
activité de telle sorte que l'entreprise
puisse comprendre qu'est-ce qui peut lui
arriver s'il y a une contrainte qui
arrive sur enfin c'est une contrainte
vient sur les émissions dont elle dépend
que les émissions soient juridiquement
s'approprier ou pas
si par exemple ma flotte de camion est
externalisée
si on peut moins facilement faire rouler
des camions même si c'est pas les miens
je vais en voir les conséquences donc la
question était pas tellement de savoir
si on était propriétaire ou pas question
était de savoir si on en dépend et puis
chemin faisant je me suis rendu compte
que les émissions de CO2 correspondaient
à l'énergie et que l'énergie c'était ce
qui permet de mettre en route les flux
physiques l'énergie du cas oui non mais
je suis lent parfois et donc je me suis
dit en fait le Bilan Carbone c'est rien
d'autre qu'une radiographie des flux
physiques qui permettent à une activité
de fonctionner et de là je me dis en
fait tout est énergie c'est qu'il y a de
l'énergie de la transformation
absolument partout et donc en remontant
en continuant à tirer à tirer ce fil là
c'est là que j'ai commencé à faire mais
régressions là où j'ai regardé énergie
contre PIB et je me suis rendu compte
que j'avais essentiellement une droite à
l'échelle mondiale
c'est là que j'ai commencé
l'énergie plus oui oui parce que en fait
la production économique c'est là que
j'ai commencé à faire mes calculs
d'ordre de grandeur sur l'importance des
machines versus des hommes de nos
biscotos donc en fait nous tous dans
cette pièce là notre mode de vie est
dépendant d'un parc de machines dans la
puissance et entre 500 et 1000 fois
celle de nos propres muscles
c'est avec des petits calculs de cet
ordre de grandeur de cette nature que je
me suis rendu compte qu'en fait ce qui
fait tourner le monde moderne
aujourd'hui c'est les machines donc
l'énergie on supprime l'énergie on
supprime les machines on supprime le
monde moderne et en fait on en est tous
dépendant à un moment ou un autre c'est
pas juste un problème d'argent à un
moment c'est un problème de survie c'est
un problème de subsistance un truc que
je dis souvent c'est sans camion les
grandes villes nord de fin si demain
matin je supprime les camions on mange
plus dans Paris c'est comme ça
les revendications syndicales absolument
très explicite en général les
revendications syndicales des des
camionneurs des chauffeurs routiers
trouvent une oreille bienveillante très
rapidement mais ça c'est normal c'est
c'est tout à fait normal quand on a un
pouvoir de nuisance souvent on n'est pas
un pouvoir de nuisance faire respecter
oui enfin quand on a un effet de un
pouvoir de pression on s'en sert et
c'est vieux comme le monde je veux dire
voilà c'est comme ça ça touche l'énergie
tout de suite le le problème de pression
est plus important alors dès que ça
touche les flux vitaux
absolument on a un pouvoir de pression
plus important c'est absolument évident
donc c'est pour ça que les chauffeurs
routiers en plus de facilité à se faire
entendre que les fabricants de canotiers
ou de pantoufles en feutres c'est on est
bien d'accord
mais donc j'ai fini par comprendre que
les charentaises absolument donc c'est
là que j'ai fini qui maintenant a l'air
conditionné parce qu'il fait chaud et
donc c'est là que j'ai fini par
comprendre que
c'est là que j'ai fini par comprendre
que l'énergie en fait était à la était à
la base du fonctionnement du monde qu'on
appelle maintenant thermo-industriel
voilà et donc dans le cheminement dans
mon cheminement personnel en fait
l'énergie a suivi le sujet climat mon
premier centre de préoccupation a
vraiment été le changement climatique et
je suis venu à l'énergie derrière et
c'est aussi là que en écoutant un
certain nombre de pétroliers qui me
disait mais de toute façon il y a pas
assez de pétrole pour faire péter le
climat on va avoir un problème de pipi
pétrolier avant etc je me suis aussi
intéressé à la question de la
disponibilité ce que les pétroliers
appellent biloward c'est-à-dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe sous le sol quels
sont les réserves les quantités
accessibles disponibles etc
donc c'est
donc ça a été ça a été le bout du chemin
alors il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui on est
confronté maintenant aux deux défis à la
fois c'est à dire que on commence à voir
les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique s'appliquées
l'équivalent de la forêt française a
brûlé au Canada et les incendies sont
pas terminés la Grèce connaît le plus
grand feu qu'elle est jamais connue on a
un problème de disponibilité oui mais ça
fait partie de la vie malheureusement
c'est à dire que on sait très bien que
la population humaine comporte une part
heureusement pas trop élevée mais
incompressible d'abruti de de
gens qui truandent le fils qui est de
criminels et il est illusoire de penser
qu'on va gérer la société humaine à
l'avenir en s'en débarrassant totalement
c'est ça ça fait partie de la vie on
peut essayer de le minorer on peut
essayer de l'anticiper de le prévenir de
diminuer les facteurs de tension tout ça
c'est des choses qu'il faut faire qui
sont absolument indispensables au bout
du bout il en reste toujours
quelques-uns voilà donc sur les
incendies on peut prendre des tas de
mesure de prévention il en restera
toujours quelques-uns ça on peut le
baisser ça c'est très clair
on a des problèmes de disponibilité de
la ressource en eau on a des problèmes
l'Espagne d'après ce que j'ai compris va
perdre ou a perdu 80% de sa récolte de
céréales donc on commence on commence à
rentrer dans le dur en ce qui concerne
les questions climatiques et on commence
également à rentrer dans le dur en ce
qui concerne les questions énergétiques
comme je le disais en Europe depuis le
milieu des années 2000 avec cette espèce
de de stagnation dont on ne sort pas et
qui va malheureusement un jour ou
l'autre se transformer en décrue
c'est-à-dire que il va falloir se
réhabituer à avoir moins de mètres
carrés par personne des voitures qui
pèsent moins lourds qui permettront
d'aller moins loin moins vite etc
alors ça je pense que c'est vraiment le
bout du chemin quand on en sera là c'est
qu'on aura vraiment il y a quand même
beaucoup pas de rater ailleurs avant
ça c'est quand même pas le truc qui nous
menace le plus à court terme la
décroissance subie c'est quand 20 25% de
nos étudiants sont en grande privation
alimentaire c'est ça alors ça c'est une
question d'arbitrage parce qu'on
pourrait très bien dire que les
étudiants en question leur paye leur
repas et on développe pas la 6G donc à
un moment il y a quand même un sujet de
il y a quand même un sujet d'arbitrage
on peut on peut aussi dire que en France
on mange un peu moins de viande
va devoir faire avec moi alors de temps
en temps il y a une petite formule qui
est lâchée là quand Macron a parlé de la
fin de l'abondance je suis pas sûr qu'il
parlait du fromage du reste mais
fini la bamboche c'est fini la bamboche
mais en fait je pense que il y a des
formules qui sont lâchées de temps en
temps comme ça mais en fait personne n'y
croit vraiment et puis par ailleurs si
on y croit vraiment les initiatives
qu'on initie aujourd'hui on a récolte
pas les fruits
c'est que la France qui ici c'est
petites impuls ça c'est pas le sujet
parce que la France va devoir faire avec
moi quoi que fasse les autres et j'ai
envie de dire même si les autres plus
les autres se gobergent rapidement s'ils
en ont la possibilité et moi il y en
aura pour nous dans un contexte
compétition pour les ressources j'ouvre
une parenthèse sur la compétition sur
les ressources
ça sort peut-être du domaine de
compétences de professeur Jean-Marc
si nous on commence à ralentir notre
consommation
rentrer en décroissance pas subi et très
contente la décroissance heureuse où
tout le monde est content c'est échange
des fleurs dans le train et que tout le
monde est content avec un salaire
extraordinairement permettant d'avoir
2200 calories par jour
les autres pays sur l'échiquier
internationale de la guerre économique
où il y a que des requins qui nous
regardent pour nous manger nos contrats
de sous-marins nous manger nos contrats
de gauche nous manger nos capacités
énergétiques ils vont pas un peu
utiliser la France et le cadavre de la
France pour nourrir leurs propres
économie intense et nous laisser sur le
bord de la route de la mondialisation en
disant ah les Français ils avaient
quatre temps d'avance mais avant tout le
monde c'est dommage alors le chemin de
la mondialisation si il s'arrête pour
certains il s'arrête pour beaucoup
de latence oui je suis d'accord après
l'effet de latence c'est aussi un effet
de curseur c'est quand on n'est pas
obligé nous de déceler à la même vitesse
sur tous les sujets de la même manière
etc
enlever le cheval de la calèche oui on
est d'accord en face ça veut dire
ralentir en général
au figuré c'est ça que ça veut dire
décélérer aussi
donc la prenons l'exemple de la mobilité
si on se dit on va dans ce pays avoir
moins de voitures
déjà il faut bien voir qu'une large
partie des voitures qu'on utilise dans
ce pays on les importe donc elle
contribue plus à l'économie nationale
leur fabrication de contribue plus à
l'économie nationale je remplace une
partie des voitures qu'on utilise dans
ce pays par des vélos électriques que là
pour le coup je fabrique dans le pays
parce que je me doute d'un plan
industriel pour les fabriquer dans le
pays
françaises de batterie française avec
des usines de mécaniques françaises etc
le seul truc qu'on n'aura pas dans le
pays c'est les mines de faire parce que
ça on en a plus les mines de bauxite il
en reste peut-être encore un peu en
Provence mais enfin on a plus beaucoup
plus les mines de cuivre on en a pas
donc à un moment on a quand même un
sujet de matière première
voilà mais on peut quand même intégrer
les chaînes de valeur en montant
beaucoup plus à l'amant bon les Japonais
sont très bons pour faire des
dérailleurs et des pignons je vois pas
pourquoi on serait plus mauvais que les
Japonais pour faire des dérailleurs et
les pignons donc à un moment on peut
très bien décider que on réindustrialise
sur des trucs qui sont pertinents
on peut très bien décider un truc qui
est une compétence française forte
depuis toujours c'est l'ingénierie
c'est-à-dire l'organisation des grands
systèmes à partir du moment où on
commence à le penser chez nous derrière
cette exportable pour les autres et les
produits qui vont derrière sont
exportables pour les autres aussi on a
fait à cause on a eu historiquement
grâce à notre capacité à concevoir des
grands systèmes à large échelle un très
bon système ferroviaire on a toujours du
reste un très bon système ferroviaire on
a la plus grosse ingénierie ferroviaire
au monde s'y sera qui exporte et on a un
gros constructeur de train Alstom qui
exporte donc oui donc il faut bien voir
que si on commence à être bon sur
l'organisation dans un monde sous
contrainte si par exemple on met au
point des systèmes intelligents pour
gérer pour mieux gérer l'eau etc on a
quand même des grands acteurs mondiaux
dans l'eau derrière c'est des trucs qui
s'exportent donc je pense que c'est pas
une affaire de on est justement où on
est vivant je pense que c'est une
affaire de choix de filière c'est une
affaire de choix d'activité c'est une
affaire de choix de compétences sur
lesquels on mise et j'en reviens à ce
que je disais au début pour ça il faut
avoir la bonne grille de lecture il faut
avoir la bonne boîte à outils sinon on
n'est pas capable de faire les bons
arbitrages prenons l'exemple du
nucléaire moi je suis très content qui
est obtient qui en ce moment a appris 15
points de soutien dans tous les pays
d'Europe donc le soutien nucléaire si si
dans tous les pays d'Europe il a pris 15
points donc les gens qui n'aiment pas ma
position sur les nucléaire je leur dis
que je n'y suis absolument pour rien
dans le fait que les Allemands ou les
suédois ou les Finlandais sont un peu
plus supportés du nucléaire je suis sûr
d'être totalement pour rien
et bien si on si on accepte de se
redoter d'une filière à peu près
correcte ça c'est aussi un poste à
l'exportation bon donc enfin voilà donc
il y a des donc aujourd'hui on sait pas
faire des panneaux solaires à des
éoliennes bon très bien mais on s'est
quand même faire des centrales
nucléaires si on a d'autres qui en
veulent on peut peut-être le revendre
donc il y a un certain ça fait partie
encore de ce que je disais sur les
compétences françaises c'est-à-dire des
gros trucs compliqués à large-mail voilà
on est quand même globalement plutôt pas
mauvais dans ce dans ce secteur là
donc je crois pas du tout que ce soit un
domaine dans lequel on soit encore une
fois nécessairement perdant si on se
voilà autre exemple agriculture
on va devoir dans le domaine on a créé
en Europe une agriculture des commodités
faites pour de la monoculture à
l'exportation en gros enfin je
caricature un peu mais il y a un peu
plus c'est à dire qu'on a transformé nos
gars notre agriculture pour transformer
de la calorie fait aussi c'est
une calories consommées
les Hollandais ont fait pire que nous
hein
exportateur de nourriture du monde et en
fait c'est totalement dopé au
combustible fossiles c'est totalement ça
bon mais on peut très bien se poser la
question on a des agronomes dans notre
pays en plus on a un certain nombre qui
sont très motivés par ce sujet se poser
la question de c'est quoi le système
agricole qui est résilient dans un monde
où le climat change va continuer à
changer et va être instable maintenant
pendant des siècles ou la disponibilité
énergétique va être plus faible ou faut
quand même nourrir les gens et il faut
aller voir des productions qui
optimisent le sol qu'il faut pas en
préserver
restaurer d'abord on a 20 000 personnes
à l'INRA bon bah fais ça et si on arrive
à faire ça chez nous je suis
raisonnablement convaincu du fait que on
aura des trucs à vendre aux autres donc
voilà donc je suis enfin dans le domaine
économique il est bien connu que celui
qui innove de manière pertinente en
général il prend un avantage c'est c'est
un truc qui est vieux comme le monde
donc moi je suis pas du tout alors on va
prendre des baffes aussi c'est
absolument évident parti comme on est on
va en prendre on en prend déjà la petite
gifles la grande gifle je ne sais pas où
la baffe de bûcheron je ne sais pas
encore on va prendre je te pose la
question pour qu'on essaie de prendre
alors moi ce que je sais c'est que plus
on attend et plus avec le temps on va
aller de la petite gifle à la bave de
bûcheron
et plus on aura du mal à s'en relever
plus il y aura un effet de rémanence sur
les baffes qu'on va prendre qui va être
important c'est à dire que en gros le
dégât il disparaîtra pas après la baffe
il va il va il va perdurer
et donc l'attentisme aujourd'hui et pour
moi l'option perdante de façon
absolument évident et derrière il y a un
risque dont on a souvent parlé sur cette
chaîne de déstabilisation politique de
totalitarisme lavé ou direct de conflit
entre pays de etc enfin c'est absolument
évident que quand on commence à secouer
le cocotier beaucoup plus qu'il ne peut
le supporter en général il se passe des
trucs désagréables
moi ça fait je vis dans la démocratie
depuis ma naissance la chance mais
exactement j'ai bien de la chance et
après avoir un tout petit peu lu je me
rends compte que un c'est une chance et
deux c'est pas garanti pour l'éternité
bon voilà un truc par exemple qui me
fait peur bon et ça me fait plus peur
que de manger un peu moins de bœuf ou un
peu moins de poulet quoi
donc j'en arrive à ma question sur cette
stabilité alors il faut s'attendre à une
déconsommation décroissance énergétique
de à peu près de combien de pour cent
pour que ça
alors à 5 ans 2027 de 4 ans donc à 4 ans
parce que ça dépend de nos plans
il y a pas de plan où c'est cosmétique
oui alors je ne sais pas sur le alors je
peux donner il y a un non il y a un
domaine dans lequel je peux dire que je
sais c'est sur le pétrole européen on a
fait un travail aux chiffres project sur
la production à venir avec les seuls
contraintes biographe donc les
contraintes sous le sol les contraintes
géologiques sur la base des seuls
contraintes géologiques on a regardé
combien est-ce que les pays les 16
premiers fournisseurs de pétrole de
l'Europe
pouvait fournir vous pouvez aller
pouvoir produire dans les d'ici à 2050
les 16 en Europe tu comptes la Russie
avec ou là aussi n'est pas dans la
Russie était dedans la Russie c'est
l'Europe ou pas non les 16 premiers
fournisseurs européens
donc là dedans il y a les États-Unis
l'Iran l'Irak l'Arabie Saoudite le
Koweït les Émirats arabes unis la
Norvège la Russie l'Algérie enfin tout
un tout un temps
Venezuela non parce que le Venezuela va
pas à l'Europe et devine et le Venezuela
et surtout le Venezuela la production
vénézuélienne depuis le maximum ça a été
divisé par 4 enfin je veux dire ça c'est
effondré la production de pétrole au
Venezuela c'est plus du tout un
d'un producteur significatif le
Venezuela mais on n'a pas pris en compte
le Brésil qui vend pas en Europe et on
n'a pas pris en compte le Canada qui
vend essentiellement alors c'est un jeu
de chaise musicale avec les États-Unis
parce qu'en gros ils vendent
essentiellement aux États-Unis qui même
en exporte enfin bon bref
mais il empêche que donc on a regardé
combien est-ce que les 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'Europe qui sont aussi
les 16 premiers producteurs vidéo en
Brésil et Canada allez pouvoir produire
d'ici à 2050 sur la seule base de leur
contrainte géologique on a fait ça en
ayant accès à une base de données de
l'ensemble des gisements pétroliers dans
le monde qui est fourni par une société
qui s'appelle reichstad energy et on a
fait analyser les résultats par trois
experts du monde pétrolier dont l'ancien
Passeron de l'exploration de Total
qui s'appelle Marc blaizeau dont
l'ancien patron de l'évaluation des
gisements chez Total et alors lui j'ai
oublié son nom à l'époque
parce que c'est surtout marque que je
connais moi mais j'ai oublié son nom à
l'instant là mais il me pardonnera
j'espère et un ancien analyse aurienne
gaz de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie qui s'appelle Olivier rech
et donc on a demandé à ces trois-là sur
la base de cette base de avec cette base
de données faites-nous une évaluation de
ce qui vous paraît être l'hypothèse
centrale la plus probable on va dire de
la production future de ces 16 pays sans
innovation technique sans rien tout
compris sur la barre en fait parce que
l'innovation technique il y a un truc
qu'elle permet pas de violer c'est le
fait que quand il faut consacrer plus
d'un jour là extraire un jaune de
pétrole on s'arrête d'accord on peut
passer une barrière infranchissable
c'est une des caractéristiques de
l'énergie
si si on est obligé avec la
thermodynamique l'impose
il y avait les Canadiens qui ont pensé à
construire des réacteurs nucléaires pour
transformer deux joules de vapeur en un
joule de pétrole mais bon ça pour le
moment on s'attend
et donc la conclusion importante de ce
travail c'est que d'ici à 2050
l'hypothèse centrale c'est que la
production de pétrole de tous ces pays
sera divisé par deux
en combien de temps d'ici à 2050
faire en sorte que leurs exportations
vers l'Europe leurs exportations vers
l'Europe
vont être divisés par n'importe quoi
entre 2 et 20
je ne sais pas exactement par combien
quand on regarde l'histoire des pays qui
étaient exportateurs de pétrole et qui
ont passé leur pics de production
l'Indonésie l'Egypte etc ils sont ils
sont tous devenus importateurs de
pétrole pas longtemps derrière sauf que
là les 16 premiers producteurs de
mondiaux de pétrole peuvent pas tous
devenir un portateur de pétrole ça
marche pas bien qui vont garder pour eux
donc ils vont d'abord le garder pour eux
ça paraît absolument évident et ils nous
vendront le reste bon tarif préférentiel
bien entendu peu importe parce qu'en
fait avec le pétrole qui compte c'est la
quantité qu'on en a d'accord je redis
sans camion pareil meurt de faim bon
donc si on a dix fois moins de pétrole
en 27 ans comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise
si on a 10 fois moins de pétrole on a
notamment dix fois moins de pétrole pour
charger enfin pour alimenter les bateaux
au départ des ports européens comment
est-ce qu'on maintient la mondialisation
sans porte-conteneur et sans minéralier
ou avec 10 fois moins on va pas les
renvoyer à la voile quand j'ai regardé
ça il y a pas longtemps le tonnage de la
marine à voile
il était en gros le centième du tonnage
de la marine marchande moderne d'accord
donc le fait d'être passé de la voile au
moteur a permis de multiplier par 100 la
capacité de transport mondial de
marchandises donc on va pas revenir à la
voile voilà donc en fait la
enfin personne ne sait imaginé
aujourd'hui et surtout pas les
économistes maniant leur modèle
macroéconomique dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui sont incapables de traduire
une réalité physique enfin ou une
évolution physique de cette nature dans
le comportement de l'économie mondiale
personne n'en sait personne n'en sait
rien la seule chose que je sais c'est
que ce genre d'évolution alors le
paradoxe c'est que ce genre de volution
ne va même pas assez vite pour le climat
c'est à dire que pour le climat il
faudrait que la production de pétrole en
2050 soit nulle
par la moitié de ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui soit nulle mais ça va
beaucoup trop vite pour maintenir un
système stable en partant de l'économie
actuelle et en la faisant transitionner
à la bonne vitesse compte tenu des
dispositions qu'on ne prend plus
exactement qu'on ne prend pas d'accord
et compte tenu du fait qu'on continue
d'aller dans vers un système qui est pas
du tout résilient face à la décrue
énergétique continue à construire des
autoroutes à étaler l'urbanisme à avoir
des métiers tertiaires qui sont
dépendants en fait de flux longue
distance et de production industrielle
sous-jacentes qui se trouve chez les
autres maintenant et plus chez nous
enfin bon bref on n'a pas du tout
commencé à adapter le fonctionnement de
la société à quelque chose qui va
devenir si on le faisait ce sont pas
nécessairement très grave on arrêterait
d'avoir des bagnoles d'une tonne et demi
on retrouverait des bagnoles de 500 kg
et une partie d'entre nous fera du vélo
électrique et c'est pas très grave mais
sauf que pour ça il faut anticiper il
faut construire les filières de
fabrication construire les former les
compétences c'est pas la même compétence
pour réparer un vélo et pour visser et
pour faire une soudure sur une tout ça
c'est tout ça c'est pas pareil quoi
alors
rembobine un peu quand tu as compris
tout ça avec les flux énergétiques
c'était l'économie c'était notre notre
société ainsi de suite tu as prononcé
les mots magiques Eureka tu as compris
non je ne parle pas grec tu parles pas
sauf sous la torture
donc quand tu as tu as eu cet éclair de
lucidité et à te reconnecter avec les
fondamentaux de base de soutenabilité de
notre société terre ou industrielle
quand tu as une allocution de notre
ministre de l'Industrie de l'économie ou
de notre leader charismatique président
Macron
quand tu les entends parler un petit peu
de ton sujet ou des d'anticipation ou de
de plan sur la comète ou de danse sur
leur chaise ça te fait quelle cette
sentiment alors maintenant tu t'es midi
tracé à ce type de de d'intervention
publique donc ça ne te fait même plus
réagir ou des fois tu as quand même un
petit pincement ou tu t'es un petit mot
dans ta tête ou tu tu jures à la main
sur le cœur alors il faut reconnaître
une chose c'est que depuis un an ils
essayent le contexte a quand même
radicalement changé
probablement probablement amis les yeux
en face des trous probablement alors au
moment où au chiffre project on avait
fait le plan de transformation de
l'économie française c'est-à-dire on l'a
démarré au moment du covid pour un
guignol c'est pas du tout ça que
j'allais dire ça c'est peut-être vrai
mais en fait on a compris j'ai compris
un truc de plus c'est que en fait un
plan un peu massif de réorientation de
l'économie on ne le ferait que derrière
un choc c'est à dire c'est pas en
période tranquille qu'on décidera mardi
matin alors que lundi était un lundi
ordinaire tient tout d'un coup paf on va
faire la révolution c'est pas comme ça
que ça va se passer donc en fait on a
compris un truc c'est que ce qu'il
fallait c'était d'avoir les plans près
pour le moment où il y aurait vraiment
le choc qui allait déclencher la
réorientation alors je pense que la
guerre en Ukraine a joué ce rôle là le
covid
il a joué un rôle de réveil des
consciences ou un certain nombre de gens
dont moi se sont dit il faut absolument
qu'on ait un plan prêt pour la prochaine
fois enfin on est le début d'une
direction dans laquelle elle est pour la
prochaine fois et là c'est un alors
c'est pareil ce qui est en train de se
passer mais on commence à voir des
choses par exemple
au sein du gouvernement on a créé une
administration dédiée qui est le
secrétariat général à la planification
écologique qui est chargée il y a un
numéro pas vert je pense
qui est chargé maintenant les plus plus
rien est payant dans les appels
téléphoniques tout est compris dans les
abonnements forfaitaire donc le numéro
vert a plus de sens
c'est bon pour les vieux comme nous ça
le numéro vert
surtout moi mais donc
le donc c'est un organisme qui est
chargé explicitement de penser le long
terme et de penser le cadrage général il
profite des gens à l'intérieur alors
c'est des fonctionnaires et en fait
c'est beaucoup des gens de que je enfin
pour certains leur nom mettez connu
d'avant et c'est des gens qui
réfléchissent à la question depuis un
certain temps donc on réfléchisse avec
le même schéma
on est capable de se parler c'est à dire
que ils comprennent mon cadre de
raisonnement et quelque part il
l'accepte enfin je veux dire il y a il y
a une acceptation au moins partielle de
ce cadre de raisonnement d'accord
il y a quand même dans la parole
politique aujourd'hui le sujet
environnement ressources qui est
beaucoup plus présent que ça ne l'était
on a quand même fait un virage sur
l'aile en ce qui concerne la manière
dont on abordait le système électrique
on est quand même passé de Macron
ferment Fessenheim à Macron disant bon
qui aurait pu prédire voilà enfin je
vais quand même je vais quand même
partir totalement à l'opposé finalement
ça s'appelle comment ça au dessus des
toits c'est une girouette
alors quand on fait ça tout le temps
si on est un peu plus sympa quand on
fait ça une fois et pas deux on peut se
dire c'est reconnaître ses erreurs qui
se prend une tatane de bourrasques
donc il y a il commence il commence à y
avoir au niveau des ministères des
réflexions un peu opérationnelles on va
planter des arbres en 6e
on commence à s'intéresser un peu à
l'avenir de la forêt française
il avait trop tard on est bien d'accord
après 25 ans de rapports qui se sont
empilés les uns sur les autres qui
disent à peu près tous la même chose et
qui sont restés
alors il a fallu qu'on se prenne des
baffes les incendies les scolites
dépérissement etc mais ça commence à
venir
l'agriculture ça c'est toujours
électrons c'est phalogue plat le
ministère de l'agriculture est
probablement celui qui est le plus en
retard dans cette histoire parce que il
y a pas de solution à convertir de la de
la calories fossile j'y reviendrai j'y
reviendrai après je
on se perd un peu en conjecture
à l'industrie ils ont commencé quand
même à avoir à la fois un discours une
réflexion et un sujet sur les 56 les
plus émetteurs de CO2 il y a des plans
il y a sur certains de ces sites il y a
des plans industriels alors ils se font
ils se font pas mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'on a commencé à descendre à
l'étage en dessous on a commencé à
descendre un peu dans la soute et à
commencer à réfléchir à un certain
nombre de trucs qui sont qui sont
opérationnels
il y a toujours des choses qui partent
dans le mauvais sens je le redis je
comprends pas par exemple qu'on
construit de l'autoroute en Occitanie là
c'est un truc qui n'a pas de sens pour
moi
il y a des
aménagements je comprends pas par
exemple que on quitte à qui t'appartient
dans la véhicule électrique qu'on
autorise les véhicules électriques de
d'automne et demi on devrait être deux
secondes tu connais pas le plaisir c'est
pour ça non je connais pas le plaisir
mais ce que je sais c'est que les
véhicules électriques ils les font en
priorité pour des gilets jaunes il les
faut pas en priorité pour des gens qui
ont mon pouvoir d'achat ou celui des
gens qui peuvent s'acheter une Tesla
c'est pas c'est pas alors certes c'est
c'est chez ces gens là quoi faire la
marge mais quand on regarde en termes de
besoins globaux du pays c'est pas là
d'abord que ça doit aller alors
il y a eu une réponse il y a pas
longtemps sur le bonus écologique qui
maintenant va intégrer l'empreinte
carbone de fabrication des véhicules et
qui va exclure justement les véhicules
les plus lourds ou qui va avoir une
espèce de qui va inclure quelque part
implicitement une espèce de bail
européen acte
donc on commence à voir des prémices il
y a des il y a des il y a eu un coloc
qui a pas longtemps à l'Europe alors ça
c'est pas la France et l'Europe ou van
der Layenne est quand même aller
inaugurer une discussion sur la
décroissance alors moi je me méfie des
grands mots la décroissance pour moi ça
veut tout dire et rien dire mais je suis
aussi oui mais il y a quand même un
signal qui est envoyé ça veut dire vous
avez le droit d'en parler vous avez le
droit d'y réfléchir vous avez le droit
de faire des propositions c'est ça que
ça veut dire en pratique ça veut pas
dire j'ai tout compris ça veut dire le
sujet sur la table on peut en parler on
peut on peut prendre un angle différent
sur l'avenir etc c'est ça que ça veut
dire en pratique donc moi je trouve
alors je suis pas en train de dire qu'on
est sorti d'affaires pas du tout ça que
je suis en train de dire mais je trouve
qu'il y a eu un tournant depuis un an ou
un an et demi quand même et je pense
effectivement que la guerre en Ukraine a
dû jouer un rôle significatif là-dedans
sur
une partie des choses qui sont discutées
éventuellement décider éventuellement
envisager qu'on n'avait pas avant il y a
quand même une forme de libération de la
parole dans un certain nombre sur un
certain nombre de sujets sur quoi avant
qui était bloqué sur cette idée que tout
va revenir comme avant et donc c'est pas
la peine de se fatiguer à essayer de
penser des choses différemment quand à
l'époque essayer de d'y réfléchir un peu
publiquement est-ce que tu as subi une
on va dire une chape de plomb ou parce
que bon on t'a dit bon alors et
Jean-Claude c'est la Cassandre en
réalité il plombe l'ambiance le soir tu
comprends non ou bah peut-être mais on
l'a pas dit
qui se ressemble ça donc moi j'ai des
essentiellement sollicité par des gens
qui étaient intéressés par ce que
j'avais acheté parce que j'avais raconté
j'ai quand même peu été invité par des
gens qui m'ont dit alors vraiment vous
êtes un abruti fini parce que vous
racontez une anni que ni tête vous êtes
un casse-bonbon de première donc on
aimerait bien vous inviter pour vous
jeter des tomates pourries quand même
assez peu arrivé donc en pratique j'ai
été invité essentiellement enfin j'ai
toujours fréquenté des gens du reste
c'est un bien important c'est à dire que
chacun veille en midi à sa porte je sais
que il faut que je me méfie du fait que
je navigue essentiellement dans un
écosystème de gens à qui à ma cause
la première fois qu'ils m'ont invité
c'était il y a longtemps c'était
pas après la canicule de 2003 je voulais
pas dire des conneries parce que je suis
un âge où je confond un an et 10 ans
mais
non mais je je j'ai du mal à dater
parfois mes souvenirs mais c'est ça date
pas d'hier ça date pas d'hier
ils m'ont pas du tout invité tous les
étés mais
pourquoi la première fois
admettons que ce soit en 2003 alors
c'était pour parler climats ça c'est sûr
on parle d'énergie
ils m'ont jamais vraiment invité pour
parler d'énergie en fait le sujet le
sujet stress énergétique
reste un sujet beaucoup plus difficile
que le sujet changement climatique
aujourd'hui c'est très clair que c'est
un sujet beaucoup plus difficile alors
il y a plusieurs raisons à ça ça j'ai
fini par les identifier la première
c'est que le débat climatique il se fait
sur la base d'une information qui est
totalement public c'est à dire que
l'état de l'art sur la science
climatique etc tout ça est temps libre
accès c'est des publications
scientifiques alors c'est compliqué à
comprendre il faut un gros cachet
d'aspirine des fois pour y arriver mais
c'est public
le GIEC du reste ne fait que synthétiser
de l'information publique
dans le domaine énergétique
l'information qui a de la valeur est
essentiellement de l'information privée
là je parlais tout à l'heure du travail
qu'on a fait au chiffre projet dessus la
production on a dû pour ça avoir accès à
une base de données privées la base de
données de Reichstadt à laquelle nous on
a eu accès pour un prix d'amis non non
ça nous a coûté 30000 euros je crois bah
c'est je crois je crois que c'était 1%
du prix catalogue en ordre de grandeur
ça fera tout cas c'est hors de grandeur
que j'ai toujours entendu que j'ai
toujours entendu que l'accès catalogue a
ce genre de trucs c'était quelques
millions de dollars
les données pas du tout au contraire ils
étaient très contents qu'on fasse une
publication quasi académique avec leurs
données donc non non ça c'était ça ça a
posé aucun problème on était transparent
dès le début on leur a dit voilà ça doit
servir à ça aujourd'hui pas de problème
allez-y
donc alors je ne sais pas quel était
leur motivation profonde à nous laisser
faire ça mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que ils ont il n'y a pas eu de
problème
donc l'essentiel de l'information dans
le domaine énergétique et de
l'information alors l'information qui
publie c'est sur l'information sur les
réseaux électriques des on parle
beaucoup de ça du coup dans le débat
mais l'information sur les potentiels de
productions futures en ce qui en ce qui
concerne les capacités de les
possibilités géologiques sur les
combustibles fossiles c'est que de
l'information privée alors dans le
pétrole il y a des agrégateurs mondiaux
hashtag dans le gaz il y a des
agrégateurs mondiaux dans le charbon il
y en a même pas
donc en gros il faut passer sa vie dans
l'extraction charbonnière pour
exactement fréquenter des Australiens
des Américains des Chinois des Indiens
etc avoir vu la moitié des mines du
monde pour finir par se faire un avis et
en fait les quelques personnes que j'ai
fréquentées dans le charbon en France
ils ont ils ont pas du tout le même avis
sur le potentiel de production future
géologiquement possible j'ai jamais
réussi à avoir un avis consensuel
là-dessus alors que le pétrole et le gaz
j'y suis arrivé donc voilà donc c'est
vraiment la preuve que c'est donc le
débat énergétique enfin le débat sur la
limite physique en de la ressource
sur le plan énergétique c'est des
informations pas pour enfin pour la
collectivité c'est des informations qui
ne sont pas publiques et comme les
informations ne sont pas publiques le
débat public
à beaucoup de mal à prendre place donc
en fait c'est parole de machin qui dit
qu'il a de bonnes sources contre parole
de trucs qui dit qu'il a de bonnes
sources et on en sort pas et on n'avance
pas et c'est la raison pour laquelle
alors que l'évidence est la sous nos
yeux c'est-à-dire que ça fait
effectivement 10 ans plus de 10 ans
pardon que la contraction enfin que
l'Europe est en contraction subie sur
les combustibles fossiles on a plus de
ça à la transition qu'on a mise en route
on a plus de ça etc mais enfin à date
les éoliennes remplacent pas le
carburant des voitures donc c'est pas
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche donc en
fait on refuse de voir cette réalité
tout simplement parce que comme les
informations sont pas publiques il y a
pas de débat alors l'approvisionnement
européen les informations sont publiques
ça y a pas de problème le pétrole qui
est consommé par les Européens ça c'est
tout à fait public
pardon le gaz aussi et le gaz aussi
charbon aussi mais comme on n'a pas les
informations publiques sur qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir plus tard et est-ce
qu'on sera limité par les ressources
est-ce qu'on sera limité par notre
volonté de faire baisser les émissions
est-ce qu'on sera limité par encore
autre chose et bien c'est très difficile
c'est le même problème sur les
ressources minérales sur les ressources
métalliques pardon les ressources
métalliques c'est le même problème
c'est-à-dire que les données qui
permettent d'avoir le débat sont pas des
données publiques et donc on navigue
entre les évolutions de l'US géologique
absorbet qui pense à telle ou tel
professionnel du secteur qui est allé
regarder la mine de machin qui pense B
etc
des affaires les informations
géopolitiques que ça pourrait laisser
transparaître sur la santé d'un pays sur
l'économie d'un pays on peut comprendre
que ce soit un petit peu
dans le gris ou cacher est-ce que c'est
aussi pour masquer
la panique que ça pourrait entraîner
c'est à dire si on se rend compte du
jour au lendemain tu comprends le pays
producteur là-bas avec les chameaux ça
fait 40 ans qu'il raconte un peu des
billets pour avoir un impact sur la
scène internationale ou que cette mine
en question elle est pas en si bon état
que ça
si ça devient public et qu'on se rend
compte que il y a quand même un sacré
trou d'air à
à surmonter est-ce que les politiques
pourraient être aussi conscient de ça
c'est pour ça que ils essaient de faire
l'essentiel du temps
l'essentiel du temps ils se pose même
pas la question à ce point-là oui parce
que j'en reviens à ce que je disais tout
à l'heure sur leur représentation du
monde économique le monde économique est
un monde sans source dans leur
présentation enfin ou sans ou
directement sans rôle à part des
ressources naturelles dans les fonctions
de production et y compris pour les
pollinisateurs les petites bestioles qui
est dans le sang les abeilles sont
substituables avec les machines à
produire des chaussures c'est tout ça
c'est du capital c'est substituable on
en a un peu plus de là on en a un peu
moins de l'autre et WTF comme dirait les
jeunes on s'en fiche quoi c'est juste
pas le sujet
donc du coup l'essentiel du temps le
problème ne remonte pas jusqu'au
politique parce que c'est voilà quand il
remonte il pense que c'est un problème
partiel qui se règle en tant que tel à
économie constante c'est à dire que il
voit pas que si on en a moins en fait
l'économie va pas être constante et donc
enfin voilà il voit pas ce genre de truc
et les rares fois où ça remonte aux
politiques alors à ce moment
effectivement si il réalise l'ampleur de
la dépendance il peut y avoir cette
vieille maxime d'un ancien président du
conseil qui s'applique là il n'est de
problème qui ne résistent durablement à
une absence de solution
et que les Shadoks ont transformé en
patte solution pas de problème
donc voilà donc de temps en temps et
bien effectivement c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est le vide
devant l'absence de boîte à outils et
l'absence de plan B fait qu'on se dit
bon allez moi j'ai encore trois ans à
être là je vais le problème sur
le tapis les Tibétains ont un grand
proverbe pour ça tu le connais non quand
tu as un problème et que tu as une
solution ça sert à rien de t'inquiéter
et quand tu as un problème et que tu
n'as pas de solution ça sert à rien de
t'inquiéter encore plus
est-ce que ça en politique c'est porteur
de dire aux gens
la tempête arrive il faut commencer à se
serrer les coudes à fermer les volets et
à mettre du du chatterton sur les vitres
historiquement la réponse peut être oui
tu sais pourquoi on met du Chaudron sur
les vitres pour éviter que la poussière
ne passe j'imagine pour éviter que les
éclats de vertes
[Musique]
alors l'histoire a montré que de temps
en temps les politiques étaient capables
d'entraîner les pays dans la guerre
et personnellement je considère que
d'aller faire la guerre c'est quand même
plus désagréable que d'enfourcher un
vélo
ou de calorifugé un logement ou que
faire un effort économique avec une
récession ou une inflation à 25 %, c'est
l'équivalent de l'effort de guerre des
français plutôt que d'aller au même ou
même d'avoir une pièce en moins dans son
logement je veux dire je pense que il y
a des vidéos dans une seule pièce et que
tes toilette sont sur le web il y a
plein de gens qui vivent dans trop de
pièces pour eux il y a plein de enfin je
veux dire
il y a alors j'ai plus j'ai regardé les
statistiques il y a pas longtemps il
faudrait que je vérifie mais il y a
n'importe quoi entre il me semble que
c'est 30 ou 40% des logements en France
qui sont sous occupés
il faut il faudrait que je vérifie la
statut je ma mémoire me fait peut-être
défaut mais enfin c'est pas c'est pas
complètement
j'ai regardé ça il y a pas longtemps
donc en fait on a on peut très bien
aussi avoir
comment dire mutualiser les actifs
existants donc je peux en train de dire
qu'on va réquisitionner les logements
dans lesquels mais on peut très bien
avoir des trucs qui sont organisés de
telle sorte que ce soit plus facile
d'avoir plus de monde
là où il y a des grands logements et
moins de monde là où il y a des petits
logements etc
il y a beaucoup de gens par exemple qui
habitent dans des logements dans
lesquels les enfants sont partis ils
restent dans le logement
ils déménagent pas parce qu'ils sont
bien par facilité etc mais peut-être que
s'il y avait une incitation à déménager
pour un truc plus petit et
accessoirement situé plus près des
services qui sont nécessaires quand on
vieillitation c'est un petit coup de
pied ou c'est non l'hiver non non ça
peut être ça peut être fiscal ça peut
être économique ça peut être non ça peut
être faciliter la vie des gens ça peut
être il y a plein de trucs par exemple
dans les dans les travaux de rénovation
il y a une partie des gens qui l'aident
thermique il y a une partie des gens qui
les font pas alors que économiquement il
pourra être solvable pour ça tout
simplement parce que ils ont pas
confiance dans les artisans qui vont
faire ils savent pas comment s'organiser
etc tout est pas nécessairement
strictement monétaire il peut y avoir
des mesures de facilitation qui sont des
mesures où on économise du temps des
gens ou en crée de la confiance ou être
enfin voilà c'est dans l'histoire en
tout cas ce que je sais c'est que le
meilleur moyen de pas trouver c'est pas
y réfléchir
on dit réfléchir un peu tard on dirait
réfléchir trop tard
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les dans
dans les lectures que vous tu as pu
avoir sur les sociétés qui rentraient en
déconsommation en décroissance
énergétique en récession énergétique en
effondrement énergétique
dans l'histoire ça s'est matérialisé
politiquement par quoi on faisait plus
d'offrandodieux on allait couper les
oreilles des jeunes on les tuer on tue
les vieux on les abandonner dans la
jungle ça c'est matérialisé comme je
vous ai plus de guerre j'ai peu de j'ai
peu d'exemples en tête parce qu'en fait
dans l'ancien temps ou les sociétés
étaient pardon essentiellement des
sociétés agricoles la décrue énergétique
était essentiellement une décrue de la
production agricole el ninio chez les
Mayas ça a donné quoi
juste avant c'est quoi juste avant j'ai
pas regardé en détail
oui oui sûrement l'avenir est un long
passé c'est sûrement très intéressant
plus de lecture intéressante qui me
reste que de temps disponible tu dis
quoi en ce moment
en ce moment je suis en train de lire un
livre sur les ressources au Moyen-Âge
pas mal et d'un historien
en l'occurrence donc là il y avait un
long passage sur le rôle des cisterciens
dans le dans l'émergence de la
production économique voilà et
j'en suis
et j'en suis au stade de comment est-ce
que Paris est passé de la ville qu'elle
était à Lutèce c'est-à-dire 5000
habitants à une ville de 200 000
habitants c'est-à-dire la plus grande
ville la plus grande ville de l'Europe à
cette époque-là alors même que Rome qui
au moment de l'antiquité c'est un
million d'habitants j'imagine du coup
faisait beaucoup moins de beaucoup moins
mais je n'ai pas encore la réponse je
suis dans la lecture de ce chapitre
voilà ça on revient sur la question des
flux qui sous-tend d'une alimentation en
fait c'était notamment dû au système
fluvial qui permettait d'alimenter Paris
donc exactement comme Rome à l'époque de
l'Antiquité était la plus grande ville
de d'Europe parce que c'était alimenté
par voie maritime
en payant le blé de l'Egypte qui était
essentiellement un long champ au bord
d'un canal puisque le Nil ça sert de
canal donc en fait on pouvait tout faire
par bateau depuis l'Égypte depuis le
champ de blé égyptien jusqu'à Rome ben
c'était exactement le même système qui a
permis à Paris apparemment je n'ai pas
encore fini de lire c'était en fait
c'était tout le système flu qui avait
qui existait autour de Paris la scène la
Marne l'Oise etc et j'ai appris à cette
occasion qu'à cette époque c'était la
Picardie la terre la plus riche de
France enfin le sol le plus riche de
France maintenant on dit que c'est la
bosse donc ça peut arriver
et voilà donc mais on retrouve la notion
de de capacité de transport qui
permettait de faire vivre les villes
parce que c'est ça le premier sujet
c'est pour les facteurs limitant de la
taille d'une ville c'est la capacité de
transport qui permet de l'alimenter et
de l'approvisionner en bois en vêtements
en pierre etc c'est pas trop réfléchi
aux autres instances c'est pas trop
d'aménagement du territoire aujourd'hui
pour savoir
je pèse régulièrement contre des
décisions de d'augmentation du nombre
d'habitants en Île-de-France en disant
c'est le dernier des trucs à faire
aujourd'hui je le redis dans un monde
dans lequel l'approvisionnement
énergétique se contracte qu'est-ce qu'on
a en Île-de-France
des emplois tertiaires qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'un emploi tertiaire c'est un
emploi d'organisation d'un système
complexe avec beaucoup de flux physique
dans tous les sens donc c'est un emploi
qui dépend de l'énergie
à l'époque où il y avait pas beaucoup
d'énergie il y avait pas beaucoup
d'employés de bureau donc l'idée que
dans un monde sobre en énergie on va
tous être employés de bureau avec le pli
du pantalon impeccable et qu'on va taper
le carton parce que comme ça on aura
moins de temps de travail c'est tout à
fait faux ce qui va se passer dans un
monde moins avec moins d'énergie c'est
qu'on aura besoin de revenir à des
tâches productives de base et on va
recommencer à transpirer ça me paraît
absolument évident du reste on voit bien
le mouvement aujourd'hui de gens qui
deviennent bi actifs ils sont employés
de bureau la journée ils cultivent leur
potager le soir et enfin bon on voit
bien la journée ils sont chauffés rue
Bert après le soir on voit bien on voit
bien que l'évolution récente si on
regarde la masse elle est plutôt dans
donc une ville c'est ça
une ville par ailleurs aujourd'hui c'est
des compétences extrêmement pointues peu
substituables entre elles d'accord quand
on réalise des des émissions de
télévision sur Internet
demain matin on n'est pas capable de
devenir contrôleur de gestion chez
quelqu'un qui fait qui vend des pièces
détachées pour l'automobile d'accord
c'est donc c'est des c'est on est encore
et on prend pas demain matin un
magasinier dans une grande surface pour
le faire devenir instantanément
chauffeur de bus bon donc en fait pour
le mettre président d'un état
pour le moment il est toujours vivant
il se crève pas la tâche c'est ça je ne
sais pas je ne connais pas son agenda
je l'ai vu une fois dans ma vie
il est plus grand que
deux fois et deux fois c'était dans un
cas de collectif d'accord donc qu'est-ce
que tu appelles un cadre collectif on
était 10 Ah ouais on était 10 la
première fois c'était pour
l'installation du Haut Conseil pour le
climat donc on était à 10 et la deuxième
fois c'est entre les présidentielles et
les législatives quand il a découvert
qu'il fallait qu'il parle de sobriété 10
et on était une dizaine à peu près
10 sur 2 heures on parle chacun entre 5
et 10 minutes c'est ça
ça a l'intérêt d'entendre des points de
vue très condensés dont on ne sait pas
trop ce qu'il a ce qu'ils deviennent
derrière
c'est pas comme ça que on a un truc très
un débat très approfondi sur un sujet
bien bien passé
mais donc pour en revenir à la question
de
Paris en fait l'Île-de-France donc
aujourd'hui on a essentiellement des
emplois tertiaires
l'Île-de-France si elle devait même si
l'Île-de-France devait avoir une
alimentation ou la consommation de
viande était divisée par deux
on n'est pas capable de nourrir les
Franciliens avec l'agriculture
francilienne loin s'en fout on est
capable de nourrir un tiers de la
population en gros bon donc en fait
l'Île-de-France est fondamentalement
dépendante des transports longue
distance et les emplois d'Île-de-France
sont fondamentalement dépendants de flux
qui prennent place à l'extérieur de
l'île de France
si on part de l'idée que la contraction
énergétique va contracter tous ces flux
est-ce que c'est raisonnable aujourd'hui
de continuer à faire grossir la
population francilienne non qu'est-ce
qui se passe si on le fait quand même et
qu'on a quand même la contraction
énergétique et bien on a un nombre
croissant de gens qui sont sortis du jeu
par paupérisation ou chômage
qui s'énerve bah derrière ils vont
s'énerver mais au début économiquement
ce qui va leur arriver c'est
paupérisation et chômage il me semble
que on n'est pas très loin d'un certain
nombre de trucs ou
sous-emploi c'est-à-dire des gens qui
travaillent ils ont vraiment un emploi
sauf qu'ils sont payés avec un
lance-pierre etc
donc aujourd'hui faire grossir
l’île-de-france c'est une erreur
d'aménagement du territoire le plateau
professionnel l'urbanisation du plateau
de Saclay c'est une erreur d'aménagement
du territoire etc alors la taxe
professionnelle
taxe professionnelle c'est pas très
grave à partir du moment de toute façon
un impôt ne survit pas à l'activité
sous-jacente qui s’érode donc la tête de
certains
de toute façon il va falloir s'organiser
autrement donc la question sur les
villes et sur la vascularisation des
villes et de du tissu des fils donc
c'est pas modélisé la contraction chez
nos élites non pas du tout alors c'est
l'inverse si je peux faire aujourd'hui
on ne rêve que de mondialisation accrue
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a fait le plateau
de Saclay pour monter dans le classement
de Shanghai c'est-à-dire être compétitif
dans la compétition internationale des
universités mais est-ce que aujourd'hui
notre premier besoin c'est d'être
concurrentiel dans la compétition
internationale des universités ou c'est
de former des gens dont on va avoir
besoin pour gérer la situation dont on
est en train de parler depuis 1h30 ou
une heure je sais pas bon une heure et 5
minutes voilà donc j'ai une heure donc
c'est évident pour moi que on est sur le
la deuxième option donc moi le
classement de Shanghai je m'en fous
complètement ce qui m'intéresse c'est
est-ce que nous faire peur quand même
est-ce qu'on est en train ou pas de
former les compétences dont on va avoir
besoin pour gérer le monde tel qu'il va
se présenter et où on doit logiquement
espérer nous
les meilleurs quand même est-ce qu'on
est en train de former les compétences
pour ça ou pas mais tu es en train de me
dire qu'il y a pas de plan par exemple
la crue centenaire centenaire ou
centenal de la Seine il y a un plan
d'évacuation de la ville mais ça c'est
un événement que j'ai envie de qualifier
local non local et et par émanant ça
arrive une fois puis il a cru elle dure
pas un siècle je veux dire elle passe
d'accord donc il faut un peu durcir les
installations pour qu'au moment où elle
passe on souffre pas trop mais c'est pas
le sujet là moi je suis en train de
parler d'une évolution structurelle
lente d'accord et donc c'est à ça qu'on
n'est pas préparé
on est d'accord
c'est très rapide donc bah oui
maintenant quand on parle faut bien voir
que quand on parle du siècle aujourd'hui
ça peut paraître très très lointain le
siècle mais le siècle c'est l'ordre de
grandeur de la vie humaine alors ta
génération qui est au pouvoir qui a le
pouvoir d'achat qui a encore qui a son
climax
ma génération est au pouvoir oui et non
certains 61 certains représentants de ma
génération sont au pouvoir
et avec le système il y en a plein de la
génération qui sont à la retraite qui
sont déjà à la retraite pré retraités
licenciés que pour celui qui va leur
promettre quand il vote
ça va être problématique le vote avec
une décroissance énergétique alors la
démocratie va être problématique parce
que c'est évident que le rap de sucette
pour tout le monde ça ne marche que dans
un univers en croissance
donc là on va avoir besoin d'inventer
les promesses d'un monde meilleur dans
un monde dans lequel il y aura pas de
rap de sucettes matériels
donc je te donne un exemple
imagine-toi si on est pris par surprise
ça se termine mal ça c'est absolument
évident
si on n'est pas pris par surprise je
sais pas à quelle échelle de temps et à
quelle vélocité pour toi c'est surprise
et pas surpris
dire j'ai ma carte d'immunité tranquille
ou je te fais une petite assemblée genre
si sept mois avant quand même j'ai
essayé non mais des surprises on va en
avoir en permanence
on est on est parti pour un monde
volatile dans lequel on va avoir des
surprises en permanence la question
c'est est-ce que au moment où on aura le
coup de pied au cul qu'il faudra pour
commencer ou les coups de pied au cul Un
pour commencer à se réorienter à la
bonne vitesse et de façon collective
on est encore dans les temps pour éviter
les pierres emmerdements derrière les
pires emmerdements et c'est quoi on est
dans les temps justement je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas voilà quand le changement
climatique pour prendre cet exemple à
l'horizon du siècle un réchauffement de
3 degrés il pose la question de la
taille de la population et son espérance
de vie mais quand je dis ça pose la
question je sais pas si ça va ça risque
dans nos tes 5 ans disant 20 ans ou 30
ans je sais pas quoi il faut faire des
parts énergétiques avec les vieux il
faut faire je sais pas si ça risque de
poser aujourd'hui on est 8 milliards je
sais pas si c'est susceptible de porter
atteinte à la vie de 1 milliard de
milliards 3 milliards ou 300 millions je
sais pas quel est le système politique
le plus à même à pouvoir gérer ce type
de détruit énergétique
c'est quoi c'est une théocratie qui nous
faut c'est une autocratie c'est quoi je
démocratie
je ne souhaite il y a deux choses que je
souhaite pas plutôt répondre
c'est un le système qui est trop mou et
qui du coup fait qu'on meurt parce qu'on
a été trop mou et deux le système qui
est trop dur et qui fait énormément de
dégâts sur son passage donc en gros on a
le projet stalinien génial sauf que ça
passe quand même par 40 millions de
morts
je suis pas très chaud pour ça non plus
probablement qu'une partie de la réponse
reste inventée c'est-à-dire que alors ce
dont je suis totalement persuadé et en
fait c'est un peu le sens de ce que je
fais depuis maintenant 20 ans c'est que
on optimise ou on augmente la
probabilité que les choses se passent
mieux
s'il y a une compréhension dans une
fraction la plus large possible de la
population de la situation telle qu'elle
est des voies de sortie possibles et un
début d'organisation spontané quelque
part au sein de la population pour aller
dans la bonne direction alors
l'organisation spontanée c'est quoi
c'est au sein des entreprises des
collectivités locales des associations
des quartiers de qu'est-ce que je sais
enfin toutes les toutes les
organisations à petites mailles ce que
je sais c'est que plus à ce niveau là il
commence à se passer des choses qui vont
dans la bonne direction et plus on a de
chances que la cristallisation à
l'échelle de l'État se passe bien
voilà c'est la seule chose du continent
comment ça se passe
pareil je vais faire la même réponse
de il faut changer ou essayer de faire
une image de l'été la louange de il faut
changer elle est elle était approchée
par des influenceurs qui vendent du
rouge à lèvres qui vend du rouge à
lèvres non qui vendent qui vendent de la
compréhension du monde oui
non mais je fais blague à part
ça m'a l'air quand même problématique
parce que quand on connaît les échelles
de temps de vélocité de quantité de
matériaux et qu'on voit que bon
oui je suis d'accord mais je suis
d'accord mais symétriquement le covid
nous a montré par exemple que quand on
sent le problème directement dans le
souffle de la bête dans le coup là et
bien en trois mois on est capable de
supprimer 80% du trafic aérien on est
capable de donc il y a des choses qui
sont capables de se passer très
rapidement et en fait mon pari c'est ça
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est que je
pense que c'est comme ça que les choses
vont se passer et ce qui est important
c'est d'avoir réfléchi à l'avance à des
plans de telle sorte que au moment où
les choses vont se passer très
rapidement ça se passe plutôt mieux que
moi-même voilà c'est c'est c'est ça mon
pari il faut faire quoi il faut déclarer
à l'égal ou illégal des pubs pour du
super kérosène qui va pouvoir faire
voler un hypothétique avion ça failli
être fait il y a il y a une réflexion en
France interdisant de déclarer un
produit neutre en carbone
et puis finalement ça a été à caviaret
alors les mauvaises langues disent que
c'est par les acteurs du numérique moi
j'en sais rien
ça a été caviardé et ça a été transformé
en vous n'avez pas le droit de faire ça
sauf si vous publiez quelque part un
bilan carbone avec toutes les mesures
que vous faites pour réduire machin etc
à ce moment vous avez le droit de dire
que oui on est d'accord que c'est du
violon
bah c'est ça c'est ça les charmes de la
démocratie c'est lobbying contre
lobbying et voilà donc cette fois-ci on
va pas gagner la manche mais
ça faillite fait
moi je serai tout à fait partisan pour
que on supprime une bonne partie de la
pub tout ce qui est pour des produits
gras et sucrés tout ce qui est pour la
pub pour bagnole tout ce qui est pour
etc après
assumer les conséquences
je parle pas pour moi je parle
collectivement ça veut dire une baisse
du nombre de médias puisque l'essentiel
des médias commerciaux sont financés par
la pub donc si on fait ça ça veut dire
moins de média
donc il y aura nos impôts un peu de
philanthropie non mais pour la chaîne
comme comme
[Musique]
celle-ci oui mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça fait pas le ça fait pas les
basses médias ça fait pas le gros le
gros le gros des médias
et donc ça veut dire que il y aura moins
d'emplois de journalistes
et oui non mais je dis pas que c'est bon
ou mauvais je dis il faut il faut tirer
la plotte jusqu'au bout quoi que si on
fait ça
moi je préfère l'intelligence naturelle
je sais pas si elle est vraie ou bonne
mais on a plus de prise et on comprend
un peu mieux surtout que l'intelligence
artificielle souvent quand on regarde ce
qu'elle fait elle n'a d'intelligence que
le nom
économique c'est l'intelligence
économique ça recrache ce qui est rentré
quoi donc voilà moi je l'appellerai
volontiers l'intelligence normande en
fait l'intelligence artificielle parce
que quand on demande une dissertation à
chat GPT ça il y a quand même beaucoup
de on pourrait dire ça mais on pourrait
dire le contraire
pardon
parce que c'est peut-être pas un Quick
peut-être maintenant quoi c'est c'est
voilà quand je vois parce que en fait
comme ça compile des informations qui
disent tout et son contraire sur un même
sujet en fait alors sauf si on est sur
des faits où là ça va et encore même sur
des faits ça va ça va sortir
l'optimisation de la consommation des
flux énergétiques et que dans
l'intelligence artificielle je j'y crois
avec j'y crois avec de la prise de
conscience j'y crois avec de l'entraide
j'y crois avec des grilles et tous ces
bouts avec avec des valeurs humaines j'y
crois avec des projets collectifs j'y
crois avec le fait que les gens se
reconnaissent un rôle et et et et un
statut social dans cette nouvelle
organisation
je sais pas des lunettes roses c'est
comme ça que le monde fonctionne on est
en guerre il y a des étudiants qui sont
obligés de se prostituer et de 2000
gamins avant de rentrer à l'école
c'est un peu proche quand même et puis
c'est un peu notre principal fournisseur
de matière énergétique et de matière
première donc on est en guerre la paix
sur Terre les gens qui meurent de faim
et donc là tu arrives au moins il y a
beaucoup moins de gens qui meurent de
faim aujourd'hui qui a 5 siècles
ok mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
oui non mais il faut il faut moi je me
défie un peu des des grandes
affirmations tranchées mais c'est quelle
affirmation tranchée on est dans un
biotope qui est déjà un peu malade je
suis d'accord
si on part du principe que tout est
perdu on fait rien on en revient en
première tibétain tout à l'heure
je ne personnellement je suis pas câblé
j'ai peut-être un défaut que j'ai je
suis pas câblé pour me dire on peut plus
rien faire
ingénieur
donc parce que c'est il y a des gens qui
sont fatalistes en étant ingénieur je
suis pas câble comme ça
si tu vois si tu continues à voir que
bon le pouvoir politique la courroie de
transmission pour que ce soit effectif
ça continue de mouliner ou ça continue
de sculpter de l'air chaud de brasser du
ventre tu vas faire quoi grave de la fin
tu vas t'acheter un terrain en Sibérie
ou en Bretagne
tu vas faire quoi alors tu vas renoncer
tu vas faire
une Yves Cochet je reçois tous les mois
un message de quelqu'un qui me dit où
est-ce qu'il faut se mettre pour être à
l'abri des emmerdements et je fais tous
les mois la même réponse en disant si je
le savais moi-même je serais content
parce que je pense que dans le monde
interconnecté dans lequel on vit je suis
pas sûr d'avoir la réponse à cette
question
je ne sais je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
le seul truc qui me paraît pas
complètement déconnant c'est une
variante moderne de l'union fait la
force
c'est à dire le filet de sécurité ou la
garantie si les choses commencent à
parler très bien c'est le réseau qu'on
s'est constitué et finalement le nombre
de gens à qui on rend service et qui du
coup sont prêts à vous rendre service je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
parce que je crois pas du tout à la
version américaine qui est je menteur
avec du bois pour 352 ans de la viande
de bison séchée pour 40 ans 40 000
cartouches etc je tire sur tout ce qui
bouge la version juste avant c'est
l'armée dans les rues il couvre-feu oui
mais ça c'est collectif c'est un
collègue c'est un collectif dont j'ai
pas envie mais c'est collectif quand
même l'armée c'est pas un truc
individuel on fait pas une armée tout
seul bon
là je parlais vraiment du survivalisme
c'est-à-dire je je compte que sur mes
propres forces je me construis ma
forteresse personnelle et
j'emmerde le reste du monde et c'est pas
très grave
en général les gens qui me posent la
question alors je pense pas qu'ils
emmerdent le reste du monde mais il se
pose quand même la question sous l'angle
survivalisme c'est-à-dire moi tout seul
avec mes forces ou est-ce que je me mets
pour être moi je pense que soit tout
seul il y a aucun endroit où on est à
l'abri
donc la tête pardon dans sa tête enfin
physiquement quoi
et puis même si on dit on va se mettre
en Sibérie enfin je veux dire comment on
bouffe en Sibérie dans un monde dans
lequel tous les tous les plus mondiaux
sont distrctés mais qui va pas se faire
son couteau tout seul alors ici s'il en
a quelques-uns au début et que ça lui
dort toute sa vie tant mieux mais si il
doit en refaire il fait comment donc
un petit esclave
il faudrait qu'il ait du faire à
proximité qui refasse un bas fourneau
qui etc enfin bref donc non non c'est
enfin en fait moi je pense que la vraie
résilience elle est dans les systèmes
collectifs
est-ce que tu as pensé à je te coupe
est-ce que tu as pensé au fait que bon
quand il y a cette transition
rappelle-toi de la crise de 2011 en
Grèce où les gens commençaient à les
couper du bois très proches de la ville
pour aller chauffer la contrainte sur le
biotope si c'est pas anticipé ça risque
aussi de de dégueuler sur le
truc qui me paraît absolument évident et
je pense que c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui c'est le braconnage de bois
alors en France j'ai pas j'ai pas
regardé ça de près je sais qu'il y en a
eu au Liban par exemple il y a des
forêts de cèdres là qui ont été coupés
parce que effectivement quand les gens
auront plus de quoi s'acheter le gaz le
fuel ou l'électricité pour mettre dans
la chaudière et ben ils iront ils
s'achèteront un poêle à bois et ils ont
coupé ce qui est à côté c'est absolument
voilà
donc il y a une vraie menace sur le
biotope
en gros il faut bien voir que
historiquement si on prend le problème à
l'envers le charbon a sauvé les forêts
françaises
et le pétrole a sauvé les baleines et il
a aussi sauvé du reste une partie des
forêts alors sur le charbon c'est parce
que les forges étaient en train
d'aspirer la totalité de ce qui poussait
comme bois en France le minimum
forestier en France et entre 10 et 15%
de la superficie française aujourd'hui
on est entre 25 et 30
en l'an 1000 couvert forestier de
l'Europe du Nord c'est 80%
aujourd'hui c'est enfin c'est descendu
en 1850 à 15% ou à 10% là c'est en train
de remonter alors pourquoi c'est remonté
ça c'est grâce au pétrole c'est parce
que la productivité agricole
grâce au pétrole est devenu tellement
élevé que on a pu nourrir une population
croissante en diminuant les surfaces
agricoles par rapport au minimum
forestier 1850 d'accord demain matin si
on supprime les tracteurs les
phytosanitaires les engrais un régime
alimentaire constant on commence par
couper tout ce qui reste de forêt et
ensuite on pourra même plus avoir le
régime alimentaire constant donc c'est
évident que la disparition des
combustibles fossiles va créer sans
modification de ce qu'on appelle les
modes de vie une pression sur le biotope
qui sera une pression massive et en fait
on va reproduire en Europe ce qui
s'observe actuellement dans les pays
dans les pays tropicaux où on coupe la
forêt pour avoir de la production
agricole supplémentaire c'est absolument
évident alors là le driver principal
c'est la croissance démographique et le
deuxième driver c'est l'augmentation de
la viande dans la ration alimentaire
donc si câlins
lorsque j'ai écrit mon premier bouquin
j'avais proposé à mon éditeur de le
vendre avec un revolver et deux balles
pour les maladroits
revenons très de plaisanterie donc les
conséquences sont pas anticipées il y a
deux trois plans qui sont pas
synchronisés à l'échelle géopolitique
avant qu'on synchronise ça va être
compliqué on fait passer un message au
pays africain et pays en développement
leur dit bon alors je dirais pas qu'il y
a pas il y a pas du tout de plans du
tout il commence à y avoir des embryons
de bout de planche et des gens qui
réfléchissent et c'est ça pour moi la
nouveauté par rapport à yernan c'est
rien non il y avait même pas ça
aujourd'hui oui non non mais vraiment
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir des on
commence à voir arriver des gens qui
sont qui ont vraiment envie de réfléchir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans la situation
dans laquelle on est c'est si tu les
regardes
affectueux c'est tout chaud si tu dis
faut pas décourager les gens qui
saignent c'est pas un chien j'ai pas
l'air non non bah je suis très content
je veux dire en général c'est des gens
avec lesquels on a des relations ou
professionnelles ou
assimilable a c'est des gens avec
lesquels on échange etc et on en a
besoin de ces gens-là tu regardes des
séries sur une sur Netflix ou pas
de VPN
je vais te faire plaisir
Jean-Marc je
à chaque fois que je fais la cuisine et
que ça prend un peu de temps genre une
salade parce que ça prend des plombs il
faut tout couper en petits bouts etc en
fait je mets une vidéo depuis mon père
et tu me regardes parfois bah non toi on
peut pas te regarder t'es jamais à
l'écran mais
il m'arrive de regarder des vidéos de
figure ou équivalent enfin je veux dire
son sport et la cuisine et s'endormir
c'est extraordinaire Paris
tu m'as coupé ici j'ai perdu mon fil
j'en étais à rappelle-moi c'était très
dangereux
tu regardes pas est-ce que tu as entendu
parler de la série fondation alors non
je connais le livre d'Asimov fondation
mais la série fondation non le livre toi
tu l'as lu un petit peu le livre c'est
vieux c'est vieux
rafraîchit toi si tu as l'opportunité
c'est dérivé
ça prend quelques petites largesses sur
certains comme toujours mais
regarde y voir en terme d'anticipation
des crises c'est peut-être pas mal et
des des probabilités d'aller dans un
sens ou dans l'autre c'est peut-être pas
mal aussi
est-ce que tu vois un sujet sur la
sobriété que tu aimerais aborder avec
nous est-ce que ce cache misère de nos
gouvernants pour dire qu'ils ont rien
d'anticiper qu'on va le subir et que ça
ça va s'appeler de la pauvreté est-ce
que tu veux rajouter quelques mots sur
la sobriété sur les plans sur quoi que
ce soit avant que je prenne deux trois
questions à internet
je vais rajouter par là où j'ai commencé
je pense que c'est important
c'est important que le terme soit pas
dévoyé
c'est à dire que on ne fasse pas passer
pour de la sobriété ce qui en fait
aujourd'hui est subi de façon
désorganisée
donc il faut il faut alors que les
politiques n'acceptent pas d'appeler un
chat un chat c'est-à-dire
la pauvreté pour ce qu'elle est c'est à
dire une déconsommation subie ça mais
par contre le monde médiatique lui il a
pas les mêmes contraintes
le monde
intellectuel au sens large enfin les
gens qui à un moment ou un autre
interviennent dans le débat public pour
amener des notions pour amener des avis
etc il faut pas qu'il s'y laisse prendre
voilà donc je j'insiste la sobriété elle
a un côté planifié souhaité si c'est pas
planifié et souhaité si on subit ça peut
pas s'appeler de la sobriété
est-ce que tu vois attends je vais
prendre une question une question
internet la première qui me passe
ils font des blagues
ils sont encore visibles ils sont
incorrigés
vaut mieux le sujet est un petit peu
anxiogène
d'ailleurs ce côté anxiogène comment tu
le tu le gères
ton entourage proche et ton entourage un
peu plus moi j'ai la chance sur cette
partie là de ma vie d'être entouré de
gens qui ont envie d'avancer
et comme je reste comme tous les bipèdes
sur cette terre aussi un animal piloté
par ses sens le fait d'avoir autour de
moi des gens qui sont dans un état
d'esprit positif et qui veulent y faire
quelque chose en fait c'est un antidote
extraordinaire le meilleur le meilleur
remède à l'angoisse c'est l'action
c'est absolument évident l'action sur du
rêve non l'action tout court alors des
fois elle produit que du rêve et mais
l'action en général l'action qui ne
produit absolument rien
c'est quand même c'est quand même non
c'est quand même assez rare c'est quand
même assez rare donc
le donc moi j'ai la chance d'être de
comment dire que ma vie professionnelle
elle s'exerce au sein de structure qui
sont conscientes de ce que je viens
d'évoquer au combien qui sont désireuses
de passer à l'action
qui me semble essayer de réfléchir avec
de manière pas perverse pas du tout
enfin qui me semble même qui
réfléchissent pas de manière perverse
qui essaye d'amener des trucs concrets
c'est à dire qui essaye pas juste de se
dire ah il faudrait qu'on se remuer le
Confignon mais comment est-ce qu'on fait
dans tel cas particulier comment est-ce
qu'on fait dans tel cas particulier
comme etc
donc je j'ai envie de dire sur cette
partie là mon antidépresseur il est dans
mon activité
voilà il est dans mon activité
quand on contribue à écrire une BD en
disant on va tous mourir
d'exemplaire
on se dit que déjà on va pas mourir seul
ce qui était ce qui est toujours
sympathique et ensuite on se dit que on
n'est pas seul et qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens qui ont envie qu'on se
mobilise ou qu'on avance ou quoi etc sur
ce sujet même si je me fais pas
d'illusion je sais très bien que dans
les lecteurs ou dans les gens qui ont
acheté il y en a une partie qui vont
s'en servir pour caler des meubles mais
c'est pas grave
il y a quand même je suis sûr
donc je suis suite à la BD ou pas la
réponse est oui
la deuxième question qui est quand la
réponse je ne sais pas
après pour faire de la politique non
c'est juste que en fait alors juste pour
finir sur l'histoire de la BD on a eu un
on a on a réussi à trouver un éditeur
pour la vendre aux États-Unis
sauf que aux États-Unis on est obligé de
refaire la moitié de la BD enfin surtout
Christophe pas moi parce que on peut pas
utiliser Iron Man parce que sinon Marvel
va nous réclamer un zillon de dollars
par exemple et revendu on peut le nommer
puisque c'est lui qui est droit
et donc on a dû trouver un autre
personnage qui incarnait le même le même
concept c'est à dire le concept de
l'homme augmenté par l'énergie le super
français alors on l'a moi je voulais
l'appeler super Dupont
je voulais trouver un équivalent de
super dense c'est une blague non non
donc on a trouvé un autre un autre
personnage
et puis comme les américains sont pires
encore que nous c'est à dire parlez-moi
de moi il y a que ça qui m'intéresse il
a fallu modifier tous les exemples
français pour les passer en exemple
américain
l'aventure des DFS ils s'en foutent
compte de l'an 40 donc il y a des trucs
qu'on doit supprimer
il y a le vélo c'est vraiment pas un
sujet chez eux ça autant on peut rêver
de mettre les Européens dans les villes
denses au vélo c'est juste dans les
villes américaines c'est bon ça ou leur
parler Grecs c'est pareil
donc
il y a des trucs qu'on doit modifier
et donc on a quand même beaucoup
beaucoup baissé là-dessus et du coup ça
nous a retardé le démarrage du top 2
qui est toujours prévu c'est-à-dire on a
toujours envie de faire un top 2 mais le
boulot concret qu'on devait faire dessus
ça a pris un peu de retard
voilà donc pour en venir qu'est-ce qui
moi me fait que je m'écoules pas il y a
le fait encore une fois que je suis
placé au quotidien professionnellement
sur cette partie là donc sur la partie
professionnelle je suis dans une
structure qui est un antidote par
construction
pas de petite pilules beaucoup de sport
j'ai pas de petites pilules et je tente
de transpirer un peu de temps en temps
question éternelle bonsoir dans le monde
selon Jean Marc Jancovici est-ce que les
impôts en France vont être augmentés
probablement
quand on regarde les périodes de grands
de grands efforts nationaux
si on regarde la reconstruction
si on regarde la ce qui s'est passé au
moment de la guerre aux États-Unis
le taux de prélèvement la seconde le
taux de la Seconde Guerre mondiale le
taux de prélèvement obligatoire a
considérablement augmenté du reste les
États-Unis dans l'après-guerre ils
avaient un taux d'impôt sur le revenu
qui était confisquatoire
c'était quelques centaines de milliers
de dollars mais enfin c'était quand même
c'était confiscatoire
donc moi je suis pas fiscaliste je par
ailleurs je ne fais pas de proposition
au sein du chiffre projet par exemple on
travaille pas sur la fiscalité on fait
pas de proposition par contre ce que je
me dis c'est si on me demande mon avis à
moi qui n'engage que moi qui n'engage
pas les structures auxquelles
j'appartiens
est-ce que dans un effort collectif
intense le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire augmente la réponse est
probablement oui après est-ce que les
gens ils perdent pas nécessairement
parce qu'il faut bien voir que les
impôts c'est juste un vaste communicant
c'est-à-dire que on me prend dans ma
poche de droite ce qu'on me redistribue
dans ma poche de gauche sous forme
d'infrastructure de service public etc
ça commence à caler un petit peu alors
là où ça devient pas une bonne affaire
c'est quand on quand on prend dans ma
poche de gauche pour redistribuer sous
forme d'intérêt aux détenteurs de la
dette voilà ça c'est pas un truc qui
m'arrange tellement par contre donc on
va peut-être avoir un sujet sur la dette
à l'avenir
ça a commencé à discuter avec Bruno Le
Maire toi non non plus l'argent magique
non non non
est-ce que la
comme les impôts donc plutôt est-ce que
la dette c'est des promesses de calories
futures qu'on va trouver oui il y a un
américain avec qui j'ai discuté il y a
pas longtemps que j'ai que je trouve
très intéressant qui s'appelle Nate
agains
il a un podcast qui s'appelle la grande
simplification enfin en anglais The
Great sable application il va alors j'ai
découvert son podcast parce qu'il m'a
invité c'est ça le charme d'être invité
à droite et à gauche de temps en temps
on découvre des trucs géniaux tout
simplement parce qu'on est invité et il
a une manière de dire les choses sur
l'énergie et l'argent que je trouve
extraordinaire il dit
la
l'argent en fait c'est à claim un une
revendication une revendication sur
l'énergie c'est un droit à accéder à
l'énergie en fait et la dette c'est un
droit à accéder à l'énergie future je
trouve que c'est pas mal comme comme
manière de présenter les choses parce
qu'effectivement la dette c'est
s'attendre à être repayé par quoi on est
repayé par une activité future qu'est-ce
qui permet l'activité future l'énergie
la couverture la française
de pétrole non mais ça serait un truc
marrant à faire ça tient on l'a déjà
fait avec la communauté on s'amuse bien
70 on était entre 69 et 72 selon la
source
en termes de consommation française
69 ans de consommation ou 70 ans de
consommation française
des chiffres d'aujourd'hui les
Etats-Unis c'était moins que ça c'est
intéressant
et donc la grande simplification ça tu
nous le conseille rappelle nous le site
internet en question ou le blog ou le
podcast
j'ai fait un c'était blablon qui était
Profa qui j'ai été stagiaire aux
États-Unis dans mes jeunes années mais à
quel tech non pas du tout
[Rires]
j'étais dans une antenne dans cette
d'orange à l'époque qui s'appelait
France Télécom c'était pas la DGSE
est-ce que les services de renseignement
ils t'ont posé des petites questions ils
sont venus à ta porte en disant
Jean-Marc alors non j'ai jamais eu de
contacts explicite avec les services de
renseignement mais implicite ça marche
aussi alors je implicite je ne sais pas
mais explicite non
il y a un jour une personne du ministère
de l'Intérieur qui m'a écrit pour en
disant j'aimerais bien vous devez vous
parler et puis c'est rentré dans la
liste des 60 personnes
à qui je me dis il faut un jour que je
vais répondre en lui proposant quelque
chose et puis c'était en quelle année ça
il voulait parler de je ne sais pas
en cas de décroissance énergétique je ne
sais pas exactement
je ne sais pas exactement de quoi de
quoi il voulait parler donc les impôts
ça augmente
ça me paraît logique à partir du moment
où on a besoin d'un système très
collectif d'entraide la contrepartie
logique c'est que on a une contribution
à la collectivité qui augmente alors ça
peut se traduire par des impôts ça peut
se traduire par le service civique qui a
5 ans ça peut j'en sais rien mais d'un
turquois en nature mais à un moment ou
un autre ça veut dire qu'on va
contribuer à la collectivité de façon
plus importante il y a des gens qui ont
fait tourner un modèle économique il y a
pas longtemps que ça a été publié dans
un papier qui a été publié dans
ecological economic si mémoire est bonne
ils ont regardé dans un contexte dans
lequel il y a toujours de la croissance
économique quand même mais on décarbonne
à vitesse accélérée
et les conséquences économiques qu'ils
en tirent c'est la part de formation
brute de capital fixe dans l'économie il
passe à 40%. alors qu'aujourd'hui on est
à 20
on obtient le plein emploi il y a de
l'inflation partout
il y a une inflation de dingue c'est
quoi de dingue
comme ça donc sur trois ans ça fait
combien
et donc ça veut dire en gros que c'est
une société dans laquelle on consomme
moins on stoppe dessus on contribue plus
aux infrastructures collectives on a du
boulot non non on compte là il a regardé
juste l'aspect économique donc il y a du
boulot pour tout le monde mais ce boulot
consiste pour une large pas à
reconstruire les infrastructures
collectives qu'il s'agisse des champs
des haies des des voies de communication
des canaux ou des moulins ou qu'est-ce
que je vais vous les éoliennes qu'est-ce
que je veux
et donc du coup on a moins de une moins
une moins grande part de l'activité
productive qui est consacrée à faire des
chaussettes des ordinateurs des micros
et voilà et des mètres carrés donc c'est
ça c'est ça le c'est ça la conclusion de
leur travail ça équivaut quelque part à
dire que les prélèvements obligatoires
augmentent tout ça et tout ça est dans
le même esprit en gros on travaille plus
pour la collectivité
question Internet
ne devrait-on pas investir dans le
renouvelable mais je voudrais finir
cette réponse à quelque chose d'escalier
en disant que en disant que l'option
alternative qui est ça devient le bordel
le chaos l'anarchie c'est un mauvais
terme le chaos
avec le risque par exemple de conflit
un système de conflit est quand même un
système dans lequel on donne encore plus
à la collectivité que si on augmente les
impôts on donne sa vie potentiellement
on donne son temps je sais pas je pense
que les soldats Ukrainiens actuellement
ils sont un peu plus engagés dans la
contribution à la collectivité que si
juste on leur avait augmenté leurs
impôts
voilà donc il faut bien voir que
l'inflation donc en gros il faut bien
voir que quand on dit ah ce triste-cyr
est en train de souhaiter que on
augmente les prélèvements obligatoires
le triste aussi est juste en train de
dire
nos raisonnons pas dans le contexte du
passé qui est de toute façon il est
parti il a disparu c'est fini c'est
comme ça voilà je suis désolé
raisonnons dans le contexte tel qu'il va
se présenter à l'avenir et c'est dans le
contexte tel qu'il se presse et qui va
se présenter à l'avenir qu'il faut
prendre nos Paris et faire nos
arbitrages c'est dans ce contexte là
c'est pas dans le contexte du passé
voilà
on va se parler ouvertement
la grosse fiesta qu'est-ce qu'elle
suppose elle suppose qu'on est capable
de préserver son îlot de bonheur dans un
monde qui part à la dérive je te
retourne la question tu crois
bah voilà donc on n'a pas d'autre
alternative que de se dire c'est quand
même ça qu'on va essayer de faire
tu mets un billet dessus ou tu mets pas
un billet non je mets pas un billet
parce que
de kérosène
je suis pas du tout sûr que ce que je
fais va servir à quelque chose je dis
juste par les asticots dans 30 ans
probablement mais il n'empêche que
à 30 ans donc quand même pas
55 ans 55 ans
donc non
on va sauvegarder ta conscience non
heureusement est-ce qu'on pourra faire
une intelligence artificielle avec ta
voix pour s'accompter des blagues avant
de dormir
c'est parce que c'est parce que quand je
l'écoute ma voix je me dis toujours je
sais pas comment on fait pour les
supporter
surtout dans les embouteillages c'est un
vrai régal
ça augmente le stress dans les
embouteillages donc ça le disait
donc la réponse c'est pas tellement
est-ce que j'y crois c'est est-ce que
j'ai une meilleure alternative et la
réponse est non
j'ai pas de meilleur alternative et
quand tu es politique je suis pas
politique et si tu te mettais à la place
d'un politique alors c'est très
difficile pour moi de mettre à la place
d'un politique parce que tu es pas
capable c'est pas exactement ça c'est
[Musique]
dans la question imaginons que tu sois
ministre président de la République en
fait moi la réponse que j'ai envie de
faire c'est si cette situation se
produit j'ai déjà gagné parce que ça
veut dire que le schéma de
représentation du monde que j'ai et les
propositions que je porte sont déjà
acceptées donc après que ce soit moi ou
quelqu'un d'autre pour les mettre en
oeuvre on s'en fout un peu chercher pour
diriger le pays qu'est-ce que tu
répondras mais je ne pense pas qu'on va
le faire et moi si je te le dis imagine
toi
bon ça part en sucette le gouvernement
il court le 9 secondes en il court le
100 mètres en 9 secondes ils ont pris
un billet pour aller prendre l'acide
politique quelque part on va aller on va
venir te chercher je ne suis pas sûr je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on va venir
chercher Marine Le Pen
Marine Le Pen ne viendra pas me chercher
si elle vient me chercher je dis non
mais de toute façon je dis non comme je
dis non à tout le monde te demande que
tu l'évangélise un petit peu ça je le
fais
mais si elle vient me chercher
gratuitement bien sûr
j'ai toujours fait gratuitement pour le
monde politique le monde associatif le
monde syndical cracher les politiques
merde alors non non non c'est un monde
un pécunieux
la politique de pauvre c'est pas pour
eux même pas je vais dire la finance est
un monde de riche
le digital est un monde dans lequel il y
a plein de riches l'Assemblée nationale
ils sont tous pauvres par rapport à ce
que gagne n'importe quel trader oui
absolument je veux dire
de plus donc non moi j'ai pas de je
jette pas de l'eau propre sur les
politiques pour qu'il soit un petit peu
plus respectueux ou pas
si ça les conduit à mieux travailler je
pense que c'est pas idiot je prends
l'exemple du Parlement européen alors
les augmenter eux ou augmenter ou
augmenter les moyens qui sont à leur
disposition bah non c'est pas un mauvais
exemple au Parlement européen les
parlementaires européens ils ont tous un
staff de 4 à 6 personnes ils ont pas le
même régime fiscal ils peuvent commander
des études mais ça à la limite je m'en
fous c'est pas le sujet premier ils
peuvent commander des études donc quand
il y a des sujets sur lesquels ils
savent pas ils peuvent prendre le temps
de se documenter de se renseigner etc
enfin prendre le temps ou faire prendre
le temps travailler des cabinets privés
et mais je m'en fous en fait ce qui se
passe avec le système français ou le
Parlement n'a pas les moyens des
investigations qu'il doit mener c'est
que du coup on lui amène des
propositions toutes faites auxquelles il
n'a auxquelles il n'a même pas contribué
d'accord donc il faut bien voir que le
pendant de un député français a pas six
personnes à sa disposition pour creuser
les dossiers les analyser faire faire
des études d'impact etc c'est que ces
trucs là arrivent déjà fait avec des
méthodes que les députés n'ont pas le
temps de réfuter de l'extérieur dans le
temps qu'il aurait été prédigérée donc
en fait il faut bien voir que si on veut
un pouvoir politique qui est les moyens
de sa mise à niveau
un moment il faut lui en donner la
capacité
donc ça c'est pas quelque chose qui me
gêne
ça me gêne puis quand on porte sur ses
épaules le destin du pays que on soit
rémunéré à l'égal de quelqu'un qui a un
poste de cadre dans la dans le privé ça
me choque pas du tout
ce qui me choque beaucoup plus c'est
tout ce qui fait qu'on exerce ce métier
avant tout par ambition personnelle et
pas avant tout mais quand je dis
ambition personnelle c'est le goût du
pouvoir et goût de la lumière et le goût
des projecteurs beaucoup plus en général
que le goût de l'argent si on a le goût
de l'argent c'est pas ouais si on a le
goût de l'argent on fait pas on fait pas
on fait pas ce métier là
[Musique]
dans le privé
des adresses de la France il suffit de
regarder ce que deviennent les anciens
députés ils sont pas monnayables dans le
privé
qu'est-ce que tu veux leur faire faire
un type qui a été député pendant 20 ans
tu vas l'embaucher dans une boîte qui
fait des pièces détachées pour
l'automobile ou dans une boîte qui qui
distribue des hamburgers tu vas lui
faire faire quoi
donc en gros ils se mettent à être
responsable du lobbying c'est ça qui
font ils sont aux affaires
institutionnelles ou etc votre plan
c'est pas tellement bonne planque c'est
qu'ils sont pas employables sur le reste
c'est c'est juste c'est juste ça le
sujet alors quand ils avaient une
profession libérale il retourne avocat
médecin etc c'est du reste pour ça qu'on
en a beaucoup qui sont avocat médecin
etc au Parlement ok parce que avec
l'expérience de politique qui chute
sécurité c'est-à-dire que si il retourne
à leur vie civile bah il retrouve leur
job
c'est quand même enfin on est tous
preneurs d'un filet de sécurité le
George est pas la pierre pour ça
voilà un filet de sécurité pour notre
population si ils anticipent pas ils
font pas correctement leur pour une
partie de la population non
donc c'est évident
c'est le risque qu'il y a une partie de
combien j'en ai aucune idée c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure
je parlais du changement climatique
c'est évident que le changement
climatique va exercer un effet dans le
mauvais sens sur la taille de la
population je suis pas capable de dire
aujourd'hui si ça va porter sur 1% ou 50
% des gens j'en sais rien
80% de la population française qui gagne
autour 2000 balles par mois alors 2002
ou 1800 euros le salaire médian net le
salaire net médias en France me
semble-t-il de mémoire ça représente
combien de la du de la population active
le salaire médian ah bah ça veut dire
que la moitié est en dessous et la
moitié est au-dessus
on se tape une inflation de 20% ça
commence à piquer ça pique déjà les
achats alimentaires en volume ils ont
perdu allez ils ont pas baissé ils ont
perdu 14 %
ah oui c'est beaucoup baissé oui on
ralentir ils ont perdu
ou ça sert non non 14% puis alors quand
on voit la courbe c'est bon donc ça
commence déjà à piquer bon alors
tant que cette inflation alimentaire
elle fait que les gens ils arrêtent
d'acheter du coca et des pots de pâte à
tartiner que je ne nommerai pas
sucré et de voilà c'est pas très grave
mais à un moment on voit bien déjà
aujourd'hui qu'il y a des gens chez qui
c'est imposent des restrictions
alimentaires
en disant qu'ils allaient être obligé de
limiter le nombre de bénéficiaires des
repas qui qui servaient cet hiver
170 millions de repassés ils demandent
40 millions bon c'est rien à l'échelle
du pays ainsi d'avant je veux dire c'est
le centième de ce qu'on va mettre dans
la 6G ou la 5G qui nous sert à rien tous
les ans
connecté pour dire d'acheter du lait bon
on s'aperce son charme d'aller voir la
litière quand même et maintenir un bon
seuil de pauvreté ça dit à celui qui
travaille encore
tu vas accepter ta baisse de salaire tu
vas accepter tes conditions de travail
parce que même les restos du cul ils
vont pas pouvoir te donner à manger ici
c'est évident que ça peut être des
voyelles ce genre de truc c'est évident
c'est un risque
si
après il faut bien voir une chose quand
même
partout je suis pas je vais pas tresser
une couronne une couronne de laurier au
patronat mais l'essentiel des patrons
qui essayent de faire marcher leur boîte
l'essentiel des patrons c'est des petits
absolument c'est des petits patrons et
c'est pas des gens qui sont dans l'envie
délibéré du rapport de force avec les
gens avec lesquels ils travaillent je
veux dire quand on bosse dans une boîte
où il y a 5 10 ou M50 personnes on n'a
pas envie de raser les murs à chaque
fois qu'on croise quelqu'un avec lequel
on bosse donc en gros les profs de force
c'est déjà l'échec globalement quand
même dans des petites structures comme
ça c'est pas le conflit dont on a envie
question internet bonjour imaginez-vous
un mouvement politique écologiste de
droite entre parenthèses de la vraie
écologie donc
[Rires]
ça n'engage que le la personne qui
vivent alors je c'est rigolo parce que
j'en ai parlé avec quelqu'un pas plus
tard que ce matin
pas du tout pas du tout alors je vais
répondre en creux en disant où est-ce
que je vois les faiblesses de l'offre
actuelle
l'offre actuelle elle est dans ce que
j'appelle la convergence des luttes
c'est à dire qu'en gros si on appelle si
on achète la partie environnementale on
est obligé d'acheter en même temps tout
un tas de considérations
de valeurs morales sur la société
qui sont qui ont pas nécessairement de
lien avec l'environnement
mais qu'on peut pas dissocier
donc le
je suis pour un problème
environnemental qui est j'allais dire
ramener à ses juste proportions non
augmenter assez juste proportions
et qui devient un cadre de raisonnement
supra pour toutes les offres politiques
dit autrement moi ce que je souhaiterais
c'est que la totalité des partis
politiques acceptent les faits la terre
est ronde elle fait 13000 km de diamètre
elle va pas augmenter de diamètre dans
les deux siècles qui viennent
le climat s'il se réchauffe de deux ou
trois degrés on sait à peu près ce que
ça veut dire la biodiversité nécessaire
pour faire ceci cela sans sol on nourrit
pas la population etc donc je suis pour
un partage de tout ça et que après au
sein de ce partage il y a des gens qui
disent nous on pense qu'il en faut plus
pour les riches d'autres qui disent nous
on en pense qu'il en faut plus pour les
pauvres mais tout en acceptant les mêmes
faits certains qui disent nous on pense
qu'il faut plus de mondialisation
d'autres qui disent je pense qu'il faut
plus de régionalisme etc à ce moment on
a une offre diversifiée mais où on n'a
pas d'un côté des faits pris en compte
et de l'autre côté des faits pas pris en
compte et d'un côté avec les faits pris
en compte et qui sont du respect
toujours très bien pris en compte
tout un tas d'autres trucs dont on nous
dit ça vient avec et c'est pas
négociable et donc on a le choix
aujourd'hui avec une offre très
imparfaite qui est soit et du reste s'il
offre était parfaite les écolos ils
feraient pas 4% au présidentiel il
ferait 30 d'accord bon donc le fait
oui mais les leaders ils vont avec les
inscrits au parti ils vont avec etc donc
le fait qu'il fasse 4 en fait ça montre
bien et alors que quand on demande à la
population est-ce que les problèmes
environnementaux ça vous tarabuse on est
plutôt sur du 30 à 40% voire plus ça
montre bien que l'offre ne rencontre pas
la demande donc aujourd'hui il y a une
partie de la demande alors est-ce que
là-dedans il faut un parti écologiste de
droite non il faut que des parties qui
acceptent les faits et qui accepte de se
différencier sur la manière de les
prendre en compte mais pas sur leur
existence est-ce que tu accepterais toi
de devenir juge de paix aux prochaines
élections présidentielles en donnant le
label Jean-Marc Janco c'est lui il est
énergétique à quelque chose d'approchant
aux dernières présidentielle puis un
point rouge sur ta tête en sortant du
métro pas du tout mais on m'a fait dire
que je soutenais Mélenchon bon qui ont
des médias pourquoi enfin bref si les
médias je me rappelle plus de face j'ai
vu arriver ça dans dans la voilà alors
ce qu'on avait essayé de faire c'était
qu'on avait pris dans la partie
environnementale des programmes les
propositions qui étaient
convergentes avec
on va dire les propositions du chiffre
project c'est ça et les gens qui avaient
fait ce travail c'est les shifters donc
c'est les bénévoles du bénévoles ce
travail ne faisait pas de contrôle de
cohérence entre ce qui était dans la
partie environnementale et ce qui était
dans le reste or le même mélenchon avait
dit par exemple que lui il était pour
rabaisser le prix de l'essence
et le tarif aussi
et
ça ne ça ne faisait pas ça ne mettait
pas de mauvais point pour les
propositions environnementales qui nous
semblaient contre-productives donc en
mélange on dit je m'engage à faire une
agriculture moins émettrice de gaz à
effet de serre ça vaut un point je
m'engage à favoriser les transports en
commun ça vaut un point etc quand ils
disent je m'engage à fermer le nucléaire
ça valait pas moins un point d'accord on
avait compté que les trucs qui étaient
convergent avec des trucs qu'on faisait
nous mais on n'avait pas décompté de
points pour tous les trucs qui étaient
divergents
que ce soit au sein du secteur
environnemental ou à l'extérieur bon et
avec cette règle qui valait ce qu'elle
valait donc un prof bienveillant oui on
peut dire ça comme ça il se trouve que
c'était le parti de c'était LFI qui
cochait le plus de cases voilà mais avec
cette grille de notation là ça on aurait
pu en prendre une autre on aurait pu
faire comme dans les QCM une mauvaise
réponse ça annule quatre bonnes réponses
bon voilà on aurait eu un autre
classement probablement
et donc le fait que on dise voilà ce qui
ressort du voilà ce qui ressort du de
l'analyse qu'on a faite a été interprété
dans les médias comme enfin certains
médias ont dit ah bah du coup sur les
réseaux sociaux je me rappelle plus
enfin bon bref j'ai vu arriver donc le
chiffre project soutient Mélenchon donc
c'est un peu tricky ce genre d'exercice
c'était une opération donc on s'interdit
pas éventuellement de refaire ça à
l'avenir c'est à dire de reporter un
jugement critique sur les programmes
électoraux mais on va le faire avec
suffisamment de précaution pour être sûr
de pas voir arriver un retour de flamme
qui est on est favorable au vote en
faveur de tel ou telle candidat parce
que ça sera pas le sujet
question internet pourquoi ne
parlez-vous jamais des solutions telles
que les batteries à béton gravités ou à
air comprimé entre parenthèses qui
réglerait le problème du stockage de
l'énergie solaire ou encore des
centrales à pyrolyse des déchets ou de
l'énergie marémotrice alors je parle de
temps en temps de tout ça j'en parle pas
beaucoup parce que c'est des quand on
regarde quand on fait les quand on fait
les calculs on se rend compte que c'est
des solutions qui sont pas à l'échelle
ou que c'est des éléments qui sont pas à
l'échelle donc en gros s'en occuper ou
pas s'en occuper ça l'air comprimé c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement peu
dense par unité de volume en termes de
stockage d'énergie
donc en fait ça demande beaucoup de
matériaux pour stocker peu d'énergie ça
procure des stockages c'est des
stockages qui procurent peu d'autonomie
quand on s'en sert le béton gravité en
fait c'est les volants d'inertie dans
lesquels on stocke de l'énergie alors ça
c'est des choses qui sont déjà employées
parce que ça permet d'obtenir des très
grandes puissances en très peu de temps
quand on freine le volant par contre ça
emmagas ine très peu d'énergie au total
parce que l'énergie mécanique d'une
manière générale c'est des stockages
d'énergie qui sont très faibles c'est
voilà
la pyrolyse ça existe déjà la
gazéification du bois ça existe sauf que
ça on en perd en perd 50% de l'énergie
initiale au passage donc c'est voilà ça
c'est quelque chose déjà qui se fait et
ça permet d'obtenir du gaz voilà
la dernière question et l'énergie Marie
motrice ça existe déjà on a une usine
marimotrice dans la Rance en France la
Rance qui a été vendue pour un euro
symbolique pas longtemps je suis pas au
courant de ça donc ça m'étonnerait à mon
avis c'est la propriété des DF et je
pense qu'il se la garde mais peut-être
que ça vient mais ça m'étonnerait
et la Rance c'est un endroit où il y a
10 à 12 mètres de marnage c'est à dire
entre Mario et marée basse il y a 10 à
12 mètres et des endroits et malgré
cette différence extrêmement importante
puisque 10 à 12 mètres de différence
entre Mario et marée bas ça part dans la
Manche on a ça nulle part ailleurs cette
usine elle fait de mémoire 250 MW sur un
parc de production donc 0,25 gigawatts
sur un parc de production pilotable
français qui fait pas loin d'une
centaine de gigawatts donc c'est c'est
voilà donc c'est intéressant d'en avoir
et il y a deux endroits au monde où il y
a des marnages très importants c'est la
Manche et la baie d'Hudson donc on peut
on peut en faire en France on n'aurait
pas d'autres endroits où en faire parce
qu'il faut investir de rivière pour ça
et on a pris le sol qui existait donc
question internet que pensez-vous de
l'hydrogène blanc alors j'ai fait faire
un j'ai fait un petit calcul pardon sur
la balle alors l'hydrogène blanc pour
ceux qui connaissent pas parce que
l'hydrogène maintenant il a toutes les
couleurs de l'arc-en-ciel
il y a de l'hydrogène jaune il y a de
l'hydrogène bleue il y a de l'hydrogène
il y a de l'hydrogène rouge je suis pas
au courant il y a de l'hydrogène orange
je crois il y a de l'hydrogène noir il y
a de l'hydrogène gris il y a de
l'hydrogène blanche maintenant donc bon
c'est pas toutes les couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel mais pas loin
alors l'hydrogène blanche c'est celui
qui est natif sous terre et qui se forme
sous terre par des réactions entre de
l'eau et des roches qui contiennent du
fer sauf que ces processus de formation
sont très lents et les quantités
produites sont très faibles un super
gisement en France et alors en Alsace le
gisement qu'on a découvert d'après ce
que j'ai compris c'est de l'hydrogène
dissout dans l'eau donc l'hydrogène qui
se forme dans le gisement enfin d'un
sous terre se dissout dans l'eau et les
concentrations en hydrogène dans l'eau
sont-elles ou plus exactement sont
tellement faibles
que simplement pour obtenir la quantité
d'énergie qui aujourd'hui fait avancer
les camions français il faudrait
extraire 5 milliards de tonnes d'eau par
an du gisement alsacien 5 milliards de
tonnes c'est plus que le poids de
pétrole qu'on extrait sur l'ensemble de
la planète chaque année pas de quoi
faire tourner la tête quoi je pense
qu'il y a de quoi faire un peu un petit
investissement de capital risque pour
quelqu'un qui aurait envie de prendre un
pari il y a probablement de quoi faire
avancer quelques bus à Strasbourg mais
voilà
est-ce que tu vois un sujet abordé que
tu souhaites compléter est-ce que
donc on en a parlé
de choisir une belle question d'internet
mais comme il y en a beaucoup
on va alors question on va prendre la
première qui passe bonjour quel cours
module ou connaissance Jean-Marc
introduire est-il à l'école pour faire
progresser les prochaines générations
alors ça dépend à quel niveau à l'école
ça dépend si on parle de l'école
primaire ça du collège du lycée ou des
études supérieures
alors si ces sciences po c'est le cours
que je donne au mines c'est le même
pareil parce que on a affaire à des gens
qui ont suffisamment avancé dans leurs
études pour comprendre ce que c'est
qu'une addition et multiplication une
courbe linéaire etc une corrélation
si je parle de l'école plus jeune j'ai
envie de dire quelque chose qui
ressemblerait mais en version moderne à
ce qui était auparavant la leçon de
choses c'est à dire tout simplement la
description de comment le monde
fonctionne
faire comprendre que un camion ça a
besoin d'énergie que les camions c'est
ce qui permet d'amener la nourriture
dans une ville que dans une ville voilà
le genre de métier qu'on y trouve enfin
c'est d'écrire le monde c'est quelque
part une forme de quelque chose qui se
Réal hybride entre la leçon les sciences
naturelles de la physique élémentaire et
de la géographie enfin voilà
je pense que je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui serait extrêmement utile et
par ailleurs ne serait-ce qu'à prendre
correctement à lire et écrire et compter
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
serait également extrêmement utile
question Internet dont le contexte de
contraction énergétique actuelle en
Europe où l'on voit notamment les
industries lourdes allemandes
contre les enseignants
non non mais quand je dis il faut
apprendre correctement à lire et écrire
et compter je sais très bien qu'il y a
un certain nombre d'endroits dans lequel
ils en peuvent mais
ça se produit pas mais qu'ils en peuvent
mais voilà c'est juste 800 balles par
mois quand ils sont 35
donc 800 000 enseignants je suis sûr
qu'on trouvera quelques salles personnes
dedans aussi mais voilà je précise que
c'est pas une charge tranquille
dans le contexte de contraction
énergétique actuelle en Europe où l'on
voit notamment des industries lourdes
allemandes s'exiler aux États-Unis aux
USA est-ce que la réindustrialisation de
la France est un voeux pieux quid de la
relance du nucléaire alors ces deux
questions distinctes
sur la deuxième question la relance du
nucléaire est en France essentiellement
une question de volonté
de stabilité du cadre politique
et économique
parce que le nucléaire sa barrière est
une barrière de compétence c'est assez
peu une barrière de ressources le
nucléaire est très économe en Espagne il
est très économe en matériaux utilisés
par kilowatt-heure produit parce que
Leclerc est une énergie très concentrée
on compte les crayons combustibles
il faut bien voir qu'il y a autant
d'énergie contenue dans la fission d'un
gramme d'uranium que dans la combustion
d'une tonne de pétrole on est dans un
rapport de 1 à 1 million sur l'énergie
libérée par unité de masse entre le
nucléaire et la combustion donc on
charrie des quantités de matériaux à
brûler considérablement plus faible et
on charrie le contenant de manière
considérablement plus faible aussi il y
a pas besoin de faire des pipelines pour
uranium il y a pas besoin de faire des
grands réservoirs de stockage pour
uranium alors bon c'est une cochonnerie
enfin je veux dire c'est très dangereux
là où ça se passe donc on a besoin de
bien blinder l'endroit où ça se passe
mais c'est très local il y a pas besoin
de
donc le nucléaire il a ça pour lui qu'il
est très économe en ressource en
matériaux etc il a sa contre lui que
c'est des systèmes unitairement
complexes
donc c'est très simple de faire un
réseau électrique alimenté par des
centrales c'est très compliqué de faire
la centrale si je dis les choses de
manière un peu un peu un peu triviale et
c'est plus ou moins compliqué de faire
la centrale en fonction du pari qu'on
comprend sur quel est le risque concours
si on n'a pas de nucléaire au moment où
on a fait le plan Messmer
le 13 73 après les chocs pétroliers donc
73 74 l'arbitrage des risques c'était le
défaut de pétrole belle pays par terre
donc on va faire du nucléaire et on va
le faire vite et ma foi s'il y a un
pépin sur un réacteur en fonctionnement
on prévoit les dispositifs de sécurité
qui vont bien pour que ça soit pas trop
emmerdant mais le risque sur le
dariacteur est un risque beaucoup plus
faible que le risque de ne pas avoir de
réacteur d'accord aujourd'hui on a
changé l'arbitre sur les 20 dernières
années on a totalement changé cet
arbitrage des risques c'est-à-dire que
l'arbitrage des risques est devenu le
risque important c'est le risque sur le
réacteur le risque de ne pas avoir de
réacteur est nul du reste on peut s'en
sortir avec les ENR c'est quand même
hallucinant ce que tu es en train de ce
stade à ce stade je commande pas je dis
juste c'est ça le présupposé entre les
deux j'y reviendrai après je veux bien
revenir après mais à ce stade c'est
comme ça qu'on a raisonné
essentiellement sur les 20 dernières
années donc on s'est dit il y a pas il y
a pas de sanction en fait de ne pas
avoir de centrale nucléaire et après pas
de problème anticipé ouais ouais il y a
pas de problème c'est ça le système
reste aussi facilement gérable alors
qu'en fait on voit bien que c'est on
voit on commence à voir que c'est pas le
cas le réseau électrique sans système
pilotable est considérablement plus
compliqué donc c'est beaucoup plus
simple de faire une éolienne ou un
panneau solaire c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de faire le système d'ensemble
mais pour en venir à la à la question du
nucléaire donc le le nucléaire au moment
du plan Messmer on a fait des
dispositifs simple et robuste qui
fonctionne puisque c'est encore cela qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui
on fait des trucs beaucoup plus
compliqués donc c'est beaucoup plus long
à faire le risque de malfaçon en cours
de route même si c'est pas
nécessairement dangereux il y a une
soudure faut la refaire il y a faut la
refaire donc tout ça c'est des trucs qui
sont longs et compliqués ils ont qui
augmentent les coûts
et donc la bonne question pour le
nucléaire c'est si on en fait lequel on
fait est-ce qu'on fait des EPR
est-ce qu'on fait des dispositifs
considérablement simplifiés par rapport
aux EPR qui rend plus vite à construire
est-ce que on fait directement dès qu'on
peut de la quatrième génération sur des
modèles totalement différents alors dès
qu'on peut c'est dans 30 ans c'est pas
maintenant mais je veux dire on fait
juste assez depr pour boucler la boucle
et puis c'est pas ça qu'on déploie et
aujourd'hui en fait il y a un débat
interne qui me paraît beaucoup plus
intéressant que le débat sur pour ou
contre le nucléaire je vais pas dire
qu'il est tranché dans notre pays mais
quelque part oui encore une fois je
disais tout à l'heure le nucléaire a
pris 15 points de soutien en l'espace de
deux ans donc aujourd'hui des gens qui
disent on va s'en sortir sans nucléaire
ils sont devenus
très minoritaires on va dire et la seule
question il y a deux questions il y en a
que deux pour moi c'est quel panachage
on fait entre ENR et nucléaire
c'est-à-dire comment on cadence les
trucs qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'on fait après etc et en
fait il y a une troisième larron dans
l'affaire c'est évidemment sobriété et
baisse de la consommation il y a un
deuxième débat qui aujourd'hui me paraît
être totalement mis de côté c'est on
fait quel nucléaire bon et pour
l'utilisation pour faire quoi exactement
et ce débat là il me semble
urgent de l'ouvrir parce qu'aujourd'hui
on dit on va faire des opère on va très
bien enfin il y a peut-être des tas
d'autres options un système nucléaire
c'est un système qui dure le siècle
alors si on dit on va faire des opère on
sait ce qu'on va faire dans les 15 ans
qui viennent mais on fait quoi enfin
voilà donc moi il me semble que le vrai
débat vraiment intéressant à ouvrir
c'est celui sur quel nucléaire on fait
ce débat là
t'ouvre aussi le débat sur quelle
société tu veux alors comment tu
consommes et comment tu vas où
absolument parce que en fait le débat
historique pour ou contre le nucléaire
est en fait un débat qui prolonge pour
ou contre les systèmes centralisés la
vertualisme et tout ce qu'il veut ouais
enfin état versus local etc alors en
fait on voit bien que même un système
éolien et solaire est un système
centralisé c'est l'État qui a fixé les
tarifs pour faire décoller la filière
c'est l'État qui organise le réseau qui
permet à tout ça de communiquer du reste
en Allemagne ils ont un problème parce
que l'énergie locale du Nord est censée
faire alimenter les usines locales du
Sud ce qui montre bien que c'est pas
local
et on voit bien qu'on a besoin de l'État
comme maître du jeu dans cette affaire
là aussi donc l'idée qu'avec des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires on va
se passer d'un système centralisé c'est
complètement faux il devient encore plus
nécessaire le réseau
encore plus oui il devient tout autant
nécessaire
donc le vrai sujet je le redis c'est ça
alors après il y avait une deuxième
partie du coup j'ai dans la question la
première partie de la question c'était
je suis pas non je suis pas j'ai perdu
là j'ai perdu le fil chacun son tour la
réindustrialisation c'est juste après le
vieux alors est-ce que là rien
industrialisation est invoqueux ça
dépend quel réindustrialisation
si on dit qu'on va rien industrialiser
en ouvrant en France des mines de fer
bah non puisque on n'a pas de mine de
fer si on dit qu'on va rien
industrialiser en faisant des matériaux
d'isolation des
vélos
des tracteurs légers qu'est-ce que je
sais des selles pour cheval enfin j'en
sais rien il y a un milliard de trucs
qu'on apporte aujourd'hui et tout
simplement des machines à laver et des
armoires ne serait-ce que pour prendre
ces deux exemples il n'y a pas
d'électroménager quasiment il y a plus
qui est fait en France du textile enfin
voilà ça pourquoi pas après s'il faut
bien voir que on peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre si on a des
localisé c'était pour faire le bonheur
du consommateur au détriment du salarié
il y a l'action
non parce que globalement ce qu'a fait
la mondialisation c'est qu'on a
délocalisé la production dans des pays à
bas salaire donc l'actionnaire même si
l'actionnaire s'est servi au passage ça
permet quand même au consommateurs
français d'avoir ses chaussettes et ses
casseroles pour beaucoup moins cher si
ça avait été fabriqué en France donc à
partir du moment où c'est ça qui s'est
passé dans un sens il faut accepter la
contrepartie dans l'autre la
contrepartie dans l'autre section
réindustrialise la France avec les
salaires français d'aujourd'hui et on
s'est dit tout à l'heure que on n'avait
pas vraiment envie de créer des pauvres
en pagaille bah ça veut dire que les
chaussettes et les casseroles et les
frigos coûte beaucoup plus cher voilà
est-ce que on l'accepte est-ce qu'on
l'accepte pas c'est ça le sujet alors on
peut aller encore plus loin que ça en
disant bah si il coûte plus cher mais
qui dure deux fois plus longtemps c'est
peut-être pas très grave voilà donc on a
toute une réflexion à mener sur
l'arrière industrialisation c'est ça
veut dire quoi de réindustrialiser on
réindustrialise quoi dire on va
réindustrialiser d'une manière générale
ça a pas d'intérêt
dire on va choisir un certain nombre de
trucs dans lequel on pense que vraiment
s'en passer c'est vraiment descendre
c'est vraiment tomber très bas
genre le frigo je veux dire la
prophylaxie c'est à dire la conservation
des aliments
ça c'est un truc qui est absolument
central le frigo est beaucoup plus
intéressant beaucoup plus urgent
conserver que la console de jeux
connectée bon donc non mais beaucoup
plus dur sur la liste de Noël c'est
évident bon avant il y a des gens
avaient des caves donc ils pouvaient
quand on vivait à la campagne on est des
cas donc on pourrait y mettre les pommes
et les salaisons maintenant on a plus de
cave donc dans un appartement sous les
toits dans Paris comment on conserve la
bouffe déshydratation oui on peut
effectivement ne manger que des pâtes on
peut dormir
mais globalement quand même le frigo est
un truc pardon le réfrigérateur pas de
marque est un truc est un truc essentiel
donc je pense que on en revient toujours
à ce mot qui est
celui de la planification même s'il fait
un peu golf plan c'est à dire qu'il faut
qu'on accepte de prioriser nos usages de
se dire ça c'est important ça c'est
moins important et sur les trucs qu'on
priorise il faut qu'on accepte de
repartir du problème c'est à dire si ce
à quoi on veut arriver c'est un système
qui se présente comme ça à ce moment on
adapte les règles du jeu économique à ce
à quoi on veut arriver et on fait pas
l'inverse on se dit bah on est
prisonniers des règles du jeu
économiques actuelles donc on fera rien
d'autre on fait du protectionniste c'est
ça on ferme les frontières on met des
taxes alors fermez non mais un peu de
protectionnisme oui du reste on est déjà
en train de le faire l'empreinte carbone
sur la construction des véhicules qu'on
va en France c'est du protectionnisme
mais je pense que c'est du
protectionnisme intelligent mais en face
de nous
cacher mais intelligent mais en face de
nous ils sont pas ils sont pas plus
naïfs que nous l'IRA c'est du
protectionnisme
purée dur et qu'est-ce que je veux dire
et la Chine de ce prix absolument pas
d'avoir des mesures protectionnistes
quand ça l'arrange donc tout le monde en
fait donc je suis pas du tout pour un
monde dans lequel chaque pays serait
totalement fermé sur lui-même de toute
façon la France peut pas vivre dans un
monde comme ça parce que je le redis on
a pas les mines chez nous donc on est
obligé de commercialiser avec les autres
ne serait-ce que pour avoir les matières
premières donc voilà ça va plus vite on
a plus les moyens de faire ça non la
capacité de projection hors des
frontières de l'armée française c'est
30000 personnes donc ça ça marchera pas
30 000 personnes conscrites ou déjà
enrôlé enrôlé mais le temps de former
les autres on n'a pas les chars et les
avions pour les mettre derrière donc non
non tu viens de casser tous mes rêves
peut-être que il faut s'organiser
autrement ça c'est un autre sujet mais à
nouveau bon mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que on n'a pas aujourd'hui
les moyens de nos ambitions la France
est une puissance moyenne on n'est pas
une puissance de premier plan
une moyenne impuissance si on veut et
quand on voit que même une puissance
militaire de premier ordre comme les
États-Unis sans même j'allais dire sans
même pas foutu enfin c'est pas que je le
souhaitais mais n'ont pas été
physiquement capables
d'occuper un pays comme l'Irak
qui était pourtant militairement très
inférieure ça montre bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'idée qu'on va aller par la simple
coercition militaire sécurisée nos flux
logistiques lointains c'est une chimère
ça ça peut y contribuer dans certains
cas bien précis mais c'est pas du rester
chinois s'il prennent pas du tout comme
ça
ouais ouais
de façon économique mais donc
aujourd'hui mais on a il nous manque
aujourd'hui si on parle de
réindustrialisation la planification
d'ensemble et le temps long de cette
réindustrialisation parce qu'on va pas
changer d'avis toutes les semaines on va
pas dire lundi tiens je réindustrialise
sur les frigos et puis non mardi je
regarde du soleil sur les batteries et
je vais mercredi exactement et mercredi
je réindustrialise sur le textile et
puis non finalement je dis je fous le
textile à la poubelle et on va pas faire
ça on va prendre nos Paris et ça va être
bon pour 50 ou 100 ans j'ouvre une
parenthèse
quant à notre leader charismatique
Emmanuel Macron dit je ferme Fessenheim
avec tout le gouvernement qui vont on
est des bons on est des meilleurs on est
super fort start-up nation la Licorne et
l'élevage de le Haras de la Licorne et
que il change d'avis après sur des
questions de planification énergétique
ça te fait pas froid dans le dos on a
déjà eu cet échange non
je c'était à propos de la blague sur la
girouette
quand quelqu'un dont on pense qu'il se
trompait arrête de se tromper on peut
avoir deux points de vue on peut se dire
exactement donc je suis très content
qu'il ait changé d'avis où on peut donc
il est donc il a appris quelque chose ou
bien on peut se dire quel girouette il
est pas fiable bon
je préfère je préfère me dire
on va essayer de faire en sorte que on
soit dans le premier cas de figure
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne rechange pas de
nouveau d'avis derrière question
internet
un ami n'aime pas j'encovici car
j'encovici n'est pas
handicapitaliste la vraie solution n'est
pas d'abattre le capitalisme plutôt
qu'essayer de le motiver modifier de
l'adapter
je pense que le capitalisme est
consubstantiel de la démocratie
et c'est pas moi qui ai dit ça cette
ville et par ailleurs quand on voit le
rapport que le régime soviétique a eu à
l'environnement je ne suis pas
totalement persuadé que le problème soit
intrinsèquement lié au capitalisme
dernier point il faut bien voir que
quand on parle du capitalisme on ne
parle pas uniquement que de Total ou de
BNP
on parle par exemple
de l'entreprise qui édite tinkerview
je ne crois pas que tu sois
fonctionnaire voilà vous en payer par la
communauté oui mais donc ça veut dire
que tu as une structure privée forcément
voilà donc un capitaliste
au sens où il y a une propriété privée
des moyens de production
on a autorisé l'initiative privée avec
des moyens de production privée et je ne
pense pas que les gens qui sont en train
de regarder ce truc là pense que tu es
un démon incarné et que ça devrait pas
exister le capitalisme c'est le
boulanger du coin le capitalisme c'est
le plombier alors bon c'est que le
plombier il branche toujours c'est sûr
de travers mais quand même
le capitalisme c'est le coiffeur le
capitalisme c'est le réparateur de vélo
tous ces gens là sont des capitalistes
ils ont tous des entreprises privées des
petites etc donc quand on dit faut
abattre le capitalisme est-ce que il
faut que le boulanger deviennent
fonctionnaires
est-ce qu'il faut que le vendeur de
légumes du marché deviennent
fonctionnaires est-ce qu'il faut que mon
réparateur de vélo devienne
fonctionnaires je ne sais pas je suis
pas complètement persuadé que la vérité
soit là alors est-ce que ça ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas des moyens de réguler le
capitalisme à l'évidence si
à l'évidence si donc c'est pas il n'y a
pas qu'une seule nuance de capitalisme
entre le capitalisme financière
mondialisé qu'on a aujourd'hui enfin ou
plus exactement ayant accouché de
multinationales financier mondialisés et
le capitalisme de la boîte familiale de
50 personnes qui fabriquent des pipes à
Saint-Claude je pense pas qu'on parle
exactement de la même chose
les hypothèses de ces noms une
régulation du capitalisme j'ai tout à
fait pour encadrer oui oui je suis pour
éventuellement qu'on change les règles
du jeu dans lequel la capitalisme
s'exerce mais par contre dire on va
totalement supprimer la notion même de
propriété privée dans la production je
pense que les quelques-uns qui s'y sont
essayés l'expérience n'a pas été très
heureuse y compris pour leur rapport
avec l'environnement
bonsoir les hypothèses de scénario RTE
ont été réévalués est-ce que vous
soutenez le projet terawater et c'est
hypothèses vers lesquelles selon RTE se
rapprochent oui alors
c'est un scénario qui a été mis au point
par une association qui s'appelle voie
du nucléaire et qui est un scénario dans
lequel le système cible le système
électrique cible à terme c'est un
système dans lequel on a des centrales
nucléaires et des stations de pompage
alors le scénario il passe par une phase
intermédiaire où on construit en même
temps des éoliennes surtout offshore et
des stations de pompage
donc des stations de pompage c'est des
barrages réversibles c'est des barrages
avec un lac à Lamon à lac à Laval et
l'eau circule entre les deux et c'est un
moyen de stocker l'électricité
quand on a de l'électricité on pompe
l'eau à Lamon et quand on a besoin
d'électricité on la turbine vers la
balle
et les panneaux solaires d'ailleurs
pardon peut être aidé pour faire
remonter l'eau par les panneaux solaires
ou par des éoliennes ou par ce qu'on
veut et alors ce que
c'est pas très efficace
donc on a une hypothèse de consommation
électrique qui est ce qu'elle est un peu
supérieur à ce qu'il y avait dans les
scénarios RTE
et par ailleurs on a la présentation
d'un scénario dans lequel on a du à
court terme des stations de pompage et
des renouvelables en plus le temps qu'on
commence à déployer de manière accélérée
des réacteurs nucléaires dont pour
partie des réacteurs de quatrième
génération dans quelques décennies et à
terme on ne remplace pas les éoliennes
on les laisse arriver en fin de vie
quand elles arrivent en fin de vie on
les démantèle et le système après est un
système mixte nucléaire hydroélectricité
réversible et la flexibilité est assurée
par l'hydroélectricité réversible donc
en gros le nucléaire fait la base on
module un peu quelques centrales
nucléaires et c'est voilà sur le papier
c'est pas con enfin en tout cas c'est
pas con au sens de sa mairie qu'on
regarde
alors non il faut pas qu'il y ait de
sécheresse tel que on est plus le lac
Léman qu'on puisse terminer dans la
vallée dessus mais oui c'est clair que
si on a plus d'eau du tout ça marche pas
non
si on a plus d'eau du tout les centrales
nucléaires marchent pas non plus et si
on a plus d'eau du tout on a quand même
un tout petit problème pour nourrir la
population française et donc on n'a pas
d'ouvriers pour installer les éoliennes
non plus donc en fait si on a plus d'eau
du tout on est mort globalement ils sont
en train de s'entraîner pour nous faire
une remontée d'expérience avec un petit
PDF
et il y a rien du tout ni central
nucléaire ni éolienne ni population ni
rien donc
avant d'en arriver là il y a quand même
des manières de des manières de s'y
prendre qui peuvent être plus ou moins
intéressantes
voilà alors quand on dit il y a
convergence entre RTE et terawater non
il y a convergence sur l'hypothèse de
consommation d'électricité sur le reste
il y a pas du tout convergence question
internet
ouvra-t-on toujours internet en
décroissance ah bonne question à mon
avis moi
à mon avis moins pourquoi parce que
maintenir internet ça suppose des
chaînes logistiques mondiales dans
l'ordinateur là qui est en train d'être
utilisé il y a 50 métaux différents donc
ça veut dire 40 non non à peu près 40 ou
50 en faisant des heures de grandeur il
y a pas les 92 éléments du tableau de
Mendeleïev il y en a presque j'ai un
autocollant avec une petite fleur verte
qui me dit que c'est écologique oui
c'est peut-être écologique mais il y a
quand même
l'essentiel des métaux sont partisables
il faut bien voir que dans un ordinateur
l'essentiel l'essentiel des métaux de
spécialité qu'on utilise
sont diluées à des concentrations qui
sont inférieures à celles qu'ils avaient
dans la mine
donc pour le recyclage ça pose quand
même un petit problème en fait quand on
recycle un ordinateur aujourd'hui on va
recycler l'or on va recycler le cuivre
on va recycler les teint et c'est à peu
près tout le reste aujourd'hui on sait
pas recyclé parce que c'est trop dilué
le disque dur de marine Chapin je suis
sûr qu'il a été recycle les plus disque
dur maintenant il y a des mémoires c'est
des mémoires
le nom qu'elle porte mais enfin c'est
plus des disques les disques c'est pour
les vieux crabes comme nous donc
c'est des unités de stockage mais c'est
de la c'est de la mémoire c'est de la
puce c'est des puces
donc il faut en fait aujourd'hui le
digital c'est 4% des émissions
planétaires en ordre de grandeur alors
au moment où on a fait le calcul c'est
2018 maintenant ça peut être un peu
augmenté mais peu importe avec
l'incertitude qu'il y avait c'est 4%
pourquoi est-ce que c'est aussi
important parce que la moitié des
émissions la danse sont dans la
fabrication du système il faut fabriquer
les réseaux les réseaux de télécom il
faut fabriquer les ordinateurs il faut
fabriquer les serveurs il faut fabriquer
les smartphones il faut fabriquer etc
l'autre moitié dans le fonctionnement
donc il faut faire tourner tout ça et de
l'électricité dans un monde dans lequel
il y a beaucoup moins d'électricité et
beaucoup moins d'hydrocarbures
on a moins d'engins de mine qui
fonctionne on a moins d'énergie pour
raffiner les métaux on a moins d'énergie
pour transporter des trucs partout on a
moins etc donc voilà donc qu'est-ce qui
va rester d'Internet dans cette affaire
personnellement je ne sais pas la seule
chose que je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui
cramer les ressources de manière
accélérée pour qu'on puisse regarder
Netflix dans le métro me paraît être
prendre le meilleur Paris qui ne nous
reste même pas de quoi s'envoyer des
messages électroniques
dans quelques dizaines d'années
que je suis à l'adversaire de la 5G
parce que je pense que ça consiste à
brûler par les cinq par les par les par
les deux bouts il faut opérer par les
cinq bouts nos chandelles de ressources
on est en train de faire la cigale alors
que on serait bien avisé de faire un peu
plus la fourmi voilà
question internet que pensez-vous du
pilotage des maisons appartements
entreprises par domotique pour la
gestion de l'énergie si la domotique
s'appelle un thermostat je suis
parfaitement favorable si ça s'appelle
un thermostat peut être piloté par ton
ministre de de l'énergie parce qu'il a
pas anticipé que on allait dépourvu en
gaz etc la lumière à distance c'est
peut-être bien ça non je sais ça c'est
moins sympa non
c'est pas envisagé ça oui ça fait ça
fait partie des choses enfin je veux
dire le pilotage des consommations est
un truc qui peut faire partie de la
solution
après que ce soit voulu accorder pour le
moment on est plutôt plus pour le moment
on écoute plutôt du côté voulu bonjour
monsieur joncourci les JO 2024 vont
consommer plus de 2 millions de tonnes
d'équivalent de pétrole pour 15 jours
c'est 60% de la consommation de ce que
pardon c'est 60% de ce que consomme
toute l'agriculture française pendant
alors je demanderai qu'on fac check les
soucis de grandeur
aux citoyens quand il y a de tels
gaspillage bon ça c'est clair j'ai pas
le chiffre sur la consommation d'énergie
des JO il faudra vérifier voilà par
contre effectivement l'agriculture
française elle consomme quelques
millions de tonnes de pétrole par an
c'est pas c'est pas énorme
il faut continuer de subventionner le
fioul rouge pour les agriculteurs alors
pas nécessairement mais à ce moment il
faut les autoriser à passer
l'augmentation de prix dans la dans le
prix de vente
comment je fais pour me faire rayir moi
derrière si la bouffe explose dans les
frigos il faut bien voir que son prix a
considérablement baissé depuis qu'on a
des énergies fossiles c'est
malheureusement ça c'est un autre truc
qu'il faut qu'on prenne bien conscience
quand on regarde la décomposition de
l'activité des Français il y a deux
siècles à peu près les deux tiers
étaient agriculteurs si je fais
l'hypothèse totalement fausse mais juste
pour faire toucher du doigt que à cette
époque là quel que soit le métier les
gens gagnent à peu près la même chose ce
qui n'était pas vrai mais quand même ça
veut dire que le PIB français était
entre 50 et 60% agricoles
ce qui revient à dire puisque le PIB
c'est la somme des productions mais la
somme des revenus que manger coûter plus
de la moitié de ce que les gens
gagnaient à l'époque il est gens l'oubli
ça d'ailleurs aujourd'hui manger ça
coûte entre 10 et 15% de ce que les gens
gagnent et encore là-dedans l'essentiel
de la dépense c'est pas de la bouffe
c'est du salaire de magazinier c'est des
frais de transport c'est la construction
du magasin c'est c'est exactement les
campagnes publicitaires c'est les
dividendes des actionnaires de Carrefour
que tu aimes tant c'est enfin c'est tout
ça sauf de la bouffe je vais prendre un
exemple tout con que j'adore prendre
combien coûte aujourd'hui une boîte de
en une boîte de conventionnel tu parles
des œufs bio pas bio et bio extérieur
avec des OGM pas de OGM est-ce que c'est
une poule qui a vu le jour dans sa vie
la poule qui a pas vu le jour qui a pas
vu le jour du tout boîte de boîte de
prix de départ
bien sûr les eaux bio sont à 4,50 les 6
et les œufs pas bio ils sont entre 200
aux alentours de 50 un truc comme ça on
estrople ou pas en métropole en
métropole parce que en Guadeloupe la
boîte de 39 c'est 12 balles le prix de
départ le prix de départ de l'offre du
site de production alors avant
l'inflation alimentaire qu'on a connu on
était à 6 centimes donc maintenant je
pense qu'on connaît parce que c'est pas
encore passé donc maintenant admettons
que ce soit 10 ou 15 centimes même si
c'est 15 centimes 6 x 15 ça fait 90
centime
90 centimes pour une boîte d’œufs qui
avec la poule qui a pas vu le jour mais
qui en grande distribution va être vendu
4 fois ce prix là donc c'est juste trois
fois ce prix là donc c'est juste pour
dire
que sur un produit qui ne subit aucune
transformation aucune transformation
ce qu'on ce qu'on achète
voilà donc on est en dessous
donc ça veut dire que le prix de l'oeuf
départ exploitation a pas tellement
varié bon à l'époque où j'ai fait le
calcul avant l'inflation alimentaire le
prix de l'offre n'est pas exploitation
était à 6 centime
et effectivement la boîte 2 était un
euro 50 bon donc
à cette époque là on était au cinquième
entre le 5e et le quart bon donc
finalement les proportions pas dû
beaucoup changer ce qui veut dire que
quand j'achète une boîte de ce qui a
marqué sur mon ticket de caisse c'est un
euro 50 mais en fait ce que j'ai
vraiment payé ma nourriture c'est le
quart de ça le reste c'est pas acheté de
la nourriture j'ai acheté du service
j'ai acheté du transport j'ai acheté du
placement dans le rayonnage j'ai acheté
de la campagne de pub donc j'ai acheté
des médias
j'ai acheté du j'ai acheté du temps
d'antenne de M6 ou de ou de RTL enfin
voilà ce que j'ai acheté en pratique
j'ai pas vraiment acheté des œufs donc
si on regarde le prix de la nourriture
stricto sensu aujourd'hui
c'est quelques pourcents de ce qu'on
gagne
il faut malheureusement s'attendre dans
le monde de demain à ce que ça ré
augmente de manière très significative
question Internet
que penses-tu du carburant synthétique
neutre en carbone développé par je sais
pas si on a le droit de citer la marque
Porsche ah alors j'ai pas regardé dans
les détails de toute façon un carburant
neutre en carbone ça existe pas
ça
parce que aucun produit parce que aucun
produit
je suis sûr de mon coup que aucun
produit n'est neutre en carbone
dire qu'on a un produit neutre en
carbone ça voudrait dire que la
production de ce produit peut continuer
dans un monde dans lequel on met des
contraintes massives sur les émissions
gaz à effet de serre parce que s'il est
neutre en carbone il est pas concerné
par le problème
est-ce que c'est vrai elle est évident
non si je mets des contraintes massives
sur les émissions gaz à effet de serre
dans le monde je change tous les
processus de production partout et tout
le temps y compris le processus de
production du carburant de troncarbonate
voilà
en fait ça c'est un truc qui est du
marketing fait pour donner bonne
conscience à des gens qui achètent des
voitures qui devraient pas acheter
oui c'est très joli mais c'est du
bullshit
question internet on va prendre une
qu'on a parlé donc excusez-moi
pensez-vous qu'une sortie par le haut
pour être possible grâce à l'innovation
technique notamment la séquestration du
dioxyde de carbone hypothèse déjà émises
ne me coupe pas
c'est pas vrai il y a des femmes qui
viennent de poser des questions qu'on
m'a posé là je ne sais pas si c'est
parce que quand je fais une conférence
il y a que les mecs pour poser des
questions sur la technique oui ça c'est
un faute de du formatage de l'éducation
c'est
la suite de la question ça t'intéresse
pas qu'est-ce que je pense de la capture
et séquestration du carbone hypothèse
déjà émise dans les accords de Paris
dans lequel des milliardaires
investissent Bill Gates et lionne musk
et dans laquelle plusieurs sociétés
émergent par exemple Auxi et dakwan
Airbus IHT 400000 tonnes de crédit
carbone c'était une question mec alors
il y a deux processus de capture du
carbone
il y a un processus qu'on appelle le
direct aircatcher en bon français dans
le texte qui consiste à essayer de
retirer le dioxyde de carbone
directement de l'atmosphère
le dioxyde de carbone il est présent à
0,04% dans l'air
est un milieu extrêmement peu dense du
reste c'est tellement peu dense que si
j'agite les bras je ne vole pas c'est
très peu dense et donc elle est
récupérée et donc je peux passer par une
andouille une fois mais pas deux et donc
le et par ailleurs c'est un processus
une molécule qui est chimiquement inerte
le dioxyde de carbone allez récupérer
présente à 0,04 % dans un milieu peu
dense le rendement énergétique du truc
est tellement dégueulasse que en fait
j'avais fait un petit calcul d'ordre de
grandeur qui est que si on voulait
utiliser ce genre de dispositif pour
récupérer le CO2 qu'on met dans l'air
tous les ans il faudrait qu'on y
consacre en première approximation toute
l'énergie mondiale donc on aura des pots
de fleurs compostables vendus dans le
temps parfait dans lequel toute
l'énergie ne servirait que à récupérer
le CO2 qu'on met dans l'air avec
l'énergie ça serait merveilleux
alors il y a des gens qui disent mais on
va quand même en avoir besoin de ce truc
là pour respecter la partie finale des
scénarios de type accord de Paris parce
que un truc qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que dans les scénarios un point 5 degrés
et même 2 degrés
il y a une phase transitoire de
dépassement de cette température au
milieu du siècle puis derrière avec nos
petits bras musclés on fait ce qu'il
faut pour retirer du dioxyde de carbone
de l'atmosphère en net c'est-à-dire non
seulement on a des activités qui
n'émettent plus un gramme de CO2 mais en
plus une partie de la nouvelle énergie
qui n'aimait pas un gramme de CO2 est
utilisé pour retirer du dioxyde de
carbone de l'ancienne partie énergétique
de l'atmosphère je suis extrêmement
sceptique quant au fait que ce genre de
truc puisse trouver un jour son cadre
physique économique
voilà j'y crois pas vraiment donc le
derrière catcher pour le moment ça
séduit quelques personnes qui vendent du
rêve à quelques capitales risqueurs qui
ont mis quelques sous dedans mais si je
suis un peu un peu cash c'est pas du
tout une priorité je pense que ça
restera un gadget et je pense que dans
le degré que que quand on atteindra le
degré de désorganisation vers lequel on
se dirige dans quelques décennies ça
fera partie des solutions qu'est-ce que
je fais si investi mon propre argent
pour retirer du CO2 de l'atmosphère si
je rends service à l'ensemble de la
collectivité est-ce que on va encore
trouver de l'argent pour faire ça dans
un monde dans lequel il va y avoir une
compétition accrue pour les ressources
j'y crois pas donc je crois que on va
pouvoir faire des choses qui me rendent
service à moi et en fait il faut mettre
en œuvre toutes les saisissions qui me
rendent service à moi en même temps que
ça rend service à la collectivité donc
si je convainc les Français de faire un
peu plus de vélo et un peu moins de
bagnole parce que ça la rend service à
leur santé à la pollution locale et à
leur porte-monnaie j'ai une petite
chance d'y arriver pourquoi tu veux pas
leur proposer de préparation militaire
de se préparer au maniement des armes
pour aller faire les guerres à au petit
copains qui encore des ressources parce
que c'est ça revient à ce que je disais
tout à l'heure parce qu'on sécurise pas
un flux lointain de ressources
uniquement par les armes ça marchait un
peu autant des colonies mais maintenant
ça marchera plus mais on met des
pokéstellitiques sur les tanks
on y réfléchit alors pas des pots
catalytiques mais on réfléchit à les
faire fonctionner sans pétrole le un
jour on devient on deviendra pardon on
devra bien faire fonctionner une armée
sauf supposer qu'on va vivre dans un
monde de bisounours on va bien devoir un
jour avoir des moyens de défense qui ne
dépendent pas des hydrocarbures ou qui
est en dépendent moins les virus alors
tant que bah il faut espérer que non
parce que ça peut en revenir dans la
figure mais tant que on a un alors tant
qu'on a de l'énergie fossile on a du
gras quand on regarde ce que consomme
l'armée en France l'armée consomme
aujourd'hui moins de 1 million de tonnes
de pétrole par an quand les voitures et
les camions et les utilitaires en
consomment 45 40 tu comptes le défilé du
14 juillet là-dedans oui donc on a quand
même du gras
parce que on est peut-être pas tous
obligés de se balader seul dans des dans
des engins qui font une tonne et demi
bon voilà donc je pense qu'il y a un
moment enfin pendant un moment on peut
encore avoir des moyens militaires qui
ressemble à ce qu'on a aujourd'hui mais
un jour il viendra nécessairement ou ça
sera plus le cas donc de réfléchir un
peu à l'avance à comment est-ce qu'on
assure sa propre sécurité avec des
moyens qui ne dépendent pas
nécessairement des hydrocarbures c'est
pas con comme réflexion il faut le faire
du coup j'ai perdu le fil de la question
avant
donc les procédés de capture directe du
dans l'air le rendement énergétique est
tellement mauvais que je pense que on en
fera jamais quelque chose de très
significatif
là le deuxième
le deuxième processus qui est envisagé
également c'est capturer le CO2 en
sortie d'installation de grandes
combustion centrale à charbon ou
centrale à gaz à Syrie etc
CO2
ouais enfin c'est un processus
d'absorption par des amines et de
désorption derrière en chauffant les
amis voilà mais donc ça consomme donc ça
consomme de l'énergie c'est dure
longtemps ce type de dispositif il y a
ça nécessite beaucoup ça nécessite de
recycler de réalimenter en le liquide
absorbant là qui s'appelle les amines ça
nécessite d'en remettre périodiquement
parce qu'il y en a une partie qui se
dégrade de façon continue
donc ça demande un peu d'industrie
chimique derrière non ça coûte pas très
cher mais ça donne un peu d'industrie
chimique derrière
et derrière le CO2 qu'on a récupéré on
l'enfouie sous terre on l'enfouie sous
terre alors non mais c'est un truc qui
fonctionne un petit échelle on peut
l'enfouir soit dans des gisements
d'hydrocarbures épuisés
soit dans des dans des aquifères
profonds salés par exemple il y en a
plein sous la mer du Nord donc on
pourrait mettre dedans mais c'est un
processus qui demande de l'énergie et
qui fait perdre en gros plusieurs
dizaines de % de l'énergie utilisée dans
le site où on capture le CO2 on va faire
de la crèche ou la mer du Nord c'est ça
j'ai une manière de dire ça mais sauf
que si on fait ça on a pu être la
production du site ou en capture le CO2
de 20 à 40%
. voilà donc c'est ça le frein majeur à
la au déploiement à large échelle de
dispositif les économistes ont dit ça
coûte 80 euros la tonne de CO2 c'est pas
ça le sujet le sujet c'est qu'on a plus
de 20 à 40% la production du site
concerné est-ce que vous avez trois
bouquins ou tu as trois bouquins nous
conseiller ah ça c'est la question
finale non
dernière
alors j'ai lu récemment un bouquin que
j'aurais dû lire beaucoup plus jeune
mais que j'ai trouvé extraordinaire les
aventures de Oui-Oui au ministère de
l'Industrie
au ministère non c'est
de l'inégalité parmi les sociétés je
crois qui s'appelle en anglais guns and
style de Jared Diamond et qui explique
comment est-ce que
l'environnement physique
à l'échelle des milliers d'années
expliquent les sociétés qui ont dominé
les autres dans l'époque contemporaine
je trouve que c'est un bouquin qui est
extrêmement alors
probablement qu'on trouvera des
critiques etc je les trouvais beaucoup
plus intéressant que l'autre bouquin de
Jared dayermann effondrement qui a
beaucoup fait parler de lui ou il se
concentre quand même sur quelques cas
d'études les escapales les Vikings l'île
de Pâques etc toute la société mondiale
est pas comme l'île de Pâques là j'ai
trouvé que gun German seal c'était
beaucoup plus intéressant
donc ça ce bouquin là
je l'ai trouvé très bien
pour ceux qui ne l'ont toujours pas lu
je continue à recommander de l'émission
of
des époux medoz et alinéa
Italie pardon de la de 1972 s'il y a des
Belges qui écoutent
et moi je recommande le bouquin originel
pas les versions mises à jour derrière
je trouve que le bouquin original est
vraiment dans son jus extraordinaire
et dans les autres bouquins que je suis
très heureux d'avoir lu
récemment qu'est-ce que je peux citer
d'autres
je vais m'arrêter là
je vais m'arrêter là parce que le
bouquin que j'arrête Diamond est
vraiment est vraiment à lire
Bruno Le Maire non j'en ai un tout petit
peu entendu parler
ou plus exactement j'ai entendu parler
de la phrase dans tout le monde a parlé
il fait beau aujourd'hui dans le feu ça
brûle non c'est pas celle-là
d'un renflement d'un ronflement
ronflement
est-ce que un conseil pour les jeunes
générations autre que je traite mon
ronflement la nuit
alors oui j'en ai même deux c'est
intéressez-vous à ce sujet parce que il
va structurer l'avenir il ne restait pas
seul quand vous le faites
c'est à dire
parce que sinon on est pris on est pris
par le vertige du pâle vertige
l'angoisse du vide en disant
réveillez-vous c'est ça non on se dit
le truc est monstrueux quoi je
veux dire c'est donc on a besoin de on a
besoin d'un
je sais pas si je dois dire d'un organe
de psychothérapie en même temps qu'on
découvre le problème
on a besoin des voilà donc on a on a
besoin de pas être seul
face à ce problème
mais oui je fasse en général la jeunesse
moi j'ai une très belle définition de la
jeunesse c'est on est jeune tant qu'on
se croit éternel et invincible
et donc c'est quand même c'est quand
même l'époque des défis et là je trouve
qu'on en a un magnifique même si je vais
rechausser mes lunettes roses je trouve
qu'on en a un magnifique à essayer de
relever parce que encore une fois on
sait notre meilleur Paris
Jean-Marc Jancovici merci
[Musique]